hello everybody if i sound dead inside it's because i literally i i woke up like 10 minutes ago so i'm not okay right now i i'm not okay at the moment um so yes um i messed up i i fucked up so slept for the member stream um for those who were not there during the member stream um i accidentally woke up at 12 55 and then the stream was at 12 30 and it's not because i i went to bed late the first time i explained this in the membership but for the first time um in five days i actually went to bed at two in the morning which is pretty early for me because during the break I accidentally fucked up my sleep schedule because I was like oh my god I don't have to stream tomorrow that means I can stay up as long and I like it's 8 a.m.
it's 8 a.m.
oh my god it's 8 a.m.
so that was that was that's what happened the last couple of days and
And then sometimes, and we're feeling a little extra silly, sometimes it's 10 in the morning.
I'm like, yay!
So yesterday, I was like, oh my god, it's true, Samara.
I need to go to bed early.
So I actually went to bed at 2 in the morning, and then I woke up at 10 a.m.
At 10 a.m.
today.
And I ate some really good food from one of my pre-cooked meals.
It was like buttered salmon with rice.
It was so good.
At that time, I was like, I was feeling the food coma hitting me.
And I was like, I still have an hour before the stream.
It's 11 a.m.
It'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
I still have one hour.
A little bit of nap.
You have the water to anyone?
And then I overslept.
I woke up and I slept through two of my alarm.
And I was like, And then my manager called me like a minute after I woke.
I was like, why didn't you call me?
Like, that's what day?
Like, I didn't know you were awake.
It was a member stream.
Like, because he wasn't membered.
He was.
He's not membered to me because he's like I'm not I'm not using my money to member you So he was so he didn't know I wasn't streaming just because it's because he wasn't membered to me
He's like you pay me I don't have to pay use my the money you pay me to member to you
okay um um so so so he didn't he didn't know until like after when he saw people were like we're so cute he got in the discord servers apparently he's like where is she and then he called me and i was like i was like i'm already i'm like i know i know i'm awake now i'm awake Because I was so messed up and I was,
I wish, I wish you can like target gift people, uh, memberships.
I feel like that.
Like you already have membership.
I feel like target gifting would be in the next best step.
But anyway, anyway, I was so messed up that I did accidentally go live on Twitch because I forgot the last stream I did before I went on a break was on Twitch.
So I accidentally went live on Twitch.
I was like, oh fuck.
The bot's deleted though.
It's deleted.
It's like it never happened.
It never fucking happened before I went live again on members.
But anyway, anyway.
So after the, also for those who are members and was like, oh, where is she?
And then went back to sleep because you guys thought I wasn't going to show up.
Because I did show up like 35 minutes later.
I'm really sad.
We're having another member stream again next week.
Same time slot.
Third time's the charm.
I would do it until I wake up in time for it.
It would keep going until I wake up, until I wake up, until I get it right.
Same time slot.
We will do it until it works.
Surely, third time's the charm.
It's going to be at 1230 again for those who are wondering.
Um, I fell in love.
They give the five.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, also, after the memory stream, I was so very tired.
I don't know.
I think I'm just, my body was just not used to.
I fucked up.
I accidentally changed my sleep schedule.
My body's not used to waking up so early anywhere.
So my body was like, no, you need to sleep more.
And so I was like, surely it won't hurt.
Surely it won't hurt to sleep a little bit asleep again mr.
broken by thank you for the five gift the ships thank you thank you because i during the rest week um i was waking up at like three to five p.m like it bounced between those two so like my body was like it's not ready yet you're not it's like you know waiting for the fruit to get right like turn i guess like from green,
the yellow, and you're farming.
Like, it's not ready yet, so he's got it.
You're not yellow yet.
Pop-Po Smyr, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My streams will continue.
The sleeping habits improve.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did sleep a lot during the rest week.
Just not the right kind of sleep being just not the right time slots i i messed up so um so yeah so i took an hour and a half nap again because i'm like it'll be different this time around i mean you know with the amount of practice i've been having napping surely i get more used to it right like the more you practice the better you get but it's just not still the same it's it was not different i it was definitely different guys.
I was so dead.
I was so dead inside.
I still am.
I woke up like, I looked at my phone.
I was like, like, 5, 5, 30.
And I'm like, I can stay in bed for 15 more minutes.
I just need 10 minutes to prep.
I just need 10, I just need 10 minutes to prep at me.
There was my eyes for 10 more minutes.
And, um, and then I got out of bed at 5.50 and see, we made it.
I told you guys, I just needed 10 minutes.
I still made it.
I, I just shake my head.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat thingy thingy.
you remember to like this channel do can you share rights on chat to not get flagged as a bot thank you again for the super chat thank you thank you um guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you jaguans i come from the year 2040 doki is still scheduling member streams at 12 30 every week still not on time now don't say that we need member streams on other time slots guys we can't keep giving the eu all the 12th member stream time slot guys we can't keep doing that we have to diversify and then the EU goes would be like don't you please let us have this one thing and then we come on
um uh jelly thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Let's see you in Minto's birthday live on my birthday was a Yuri dream God come true Thank you for being the most beautiful and lovely cameosha dragon could ever ask for Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I legitimately don't even remember when this was recorded That was how long ago.
I remember what I told her to do But like I literally don't remember when we recorded this.
It was so long ago What did we do this anyway?
I don't remember.
It was even...
It was even before.
Like...
This was before even my...
Birthday concert.
That was how...
It was even before I did that.
That was how... Before I even prep for my birthday concert too, guys.
That was...
it was that long ago um yeah i don't even remember because i remember it being before my birthday concert uh because like when we were prepping for it um she was also in japan like when i actually finally started prepping for it she was in japan now like i was like oh this is a perfect time you're at you have access to the 3d studio too so like that's like vaguely what i remember yeah Okay,
to be fair, I've done so many of these, so it's like, what do I ask people to do?
You know, like, you know, I like, I've done so many, like, oh, do a pose stuff, but I always want to do something new.
So, so I'm like, what, I was like, dower dog, that's like the only thing you think of.
I was like, yeah, I'm give the people what they want.
I want it so I can fit as many things as possible too because you know we're like limited time slots Just like just do it like we don't need any introduction here.
We know who I am.
We don't really need any Introduction here.
Let's just do it so we can use my time slot efficiently.
Um No, we don't need filler give the people what they want.
Yeah
uh neat thank you for the five gift the ships thank you thank you um but yeah i should have googled image what downward dog looked like but all i just remembered was i was just like but but up i was just like i mean get on your knees if you want i guess uh i said naturally i lied
Um, but anyway, we're gonna be doing silk.
We're gonna continue silk sawing.
I feel like, do you guys think I could complete the game by next week?
Um, do you think I have like two parts left?
Because I think I could get to act three today and maybe play a little bit of act three.
I know act three is harder.
I don't even know what I have left to do.
Um, I don't, I honestly don't know what I have left to do.
Um, Yeah, there's no way I'm completing it today, because I haven't even got to Act 3.
I don't even know how many...
I forgot.
I hope someone's been keeping track, because I don't even know how many I've left.
But I also farmed a little bit of money off stream, too.
But yeah, you're welcome.
You're welcome, Wisp, and Wisp goons.
I gave the people what they want.
You know?
I know you guys don't want cute poses.
I give you guys what you want Thank you, Toki I'm for the people, I'm a hero
I keep you guys well fed Hero of the people Alright Okay, so What do I?
What have I done?
Oh, the lost merchant.
Oh, we have to Give Oh, we have to give all of this The song clave Where's the song clave?
I heard the song clave, wish, well And collect Is that the bell tower?
I didn't think it was a super chat Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we gotta get the Citadel thing.
Gotta do this Open this on us Tokeybird, right?
Give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Boom.
Oh, there's more people now.
He doesn't want to talk to me, but I'm going to do this.
Yay.
Wish granted.
More money.
Okay, I completed all of it.
I don't even...
Oh, wait.
Where's the merch?
That's weird.
Where is he?
All right.
You keep all the helping you and start inspiring it to others.
Best you think serious about what effect you might be coming.
Too much help could prove a dangerous thing.
Especially for all these bugs.
Starved for so long.
Look, they're so hungry.
Just like you guys.
You're so... We were like, don't you please feed us.
And I'm like, what?
Where is the merchant, anyway?
Oh, wait, my tools.
I forgot.
You're right.
All my stuff were, like, money-earning tools.
I was like, oh, shit.
Thank God.
I thank God he has told me.
They were my money-farming tools.
We gotta get the compass.
Oops.
Oh my gosh, what am I doing?
I'm too tired.
I'm so tired.
That's the farming, dude.
I'm meant to do a Jackal post next time.
I'm thinking it was Super Chatside.
Thank you.
Thing is, I remember being in a 3D debut where we've requested Jackal post.
So that's why I didn't request that.
Because that's been done before.
Like, I need something new and refreshing.
Oh, you have the witchcraft?
No, I have the hunter.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, see?
It's the hunter.
And it's the third store.
Yeah, I mean, to be fair, that war dog is literally the jackal pose.
If you think about it.
It literally is.
Except the legs are spread.
Uh, Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Shrek Kun Zeyornian Whisper Freaky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, where's the last- What's in the Citadel's Memor- Memorium?
Where the fuck is that?
Memorium?
Whispering Vault's Song Clive.
Where the fuck is the Memorium shit?
Whisp a thicket Gray more above me Oh shit it's here Okay I don't even know where it could be I'm blind I didn't realize I don't know why but I just Thought I'd be up Okay As I told you my I have a good excuse My brain is waking up right now Like Oh yeah the bug Ah Oops Oops Oops.
There we go.
There's the zoo.
I forgot he was there.
Okay, is that his stuff?
Okay, there it is.
Inspect.
Smell that.
Okay.
Oh, it's the same guy.
Why are you going outside?
You already...
You don't need to go outside anymore.
What are you doing?
I'm here to take care of you.
You're safe now, child.
Why are you still going outside?
Oh my god.
I did that on purpose.
Alright.
She just looked.
Oh yeah.
That's... Oh my god.
She went back down.
I took a fucking hit for you.
And you went back down?
God damn it.
When?
He was like, I need a far more money off of her.
Oh my god.
Where are you going?
Why?
Why are you here?
Why did you have to go there?
Oh my, oh thank god.
She didn't go further.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna be like really mad.
That is the first step.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Why are you so fast?
I'm just going to wait.
I was like, why work harder?
All right.
Oh, my God.
There's more.
Oh, shit.
How is I supposed to know there was more?
Oh.
I thought it was over.
Oh, my God.
And of course they do too.
hits.
Alright, are you okay?
No, there's more, isn't there?
Oh, it's done.
He was in the wrong neighborhood.
Oh, fine.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
This is my first time donating to anyone.
I'm glad it's you.
Can you get happy birthday from my Aoshi?
Of course you can!
Thank you so much for the support and the Super Chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Fire.
Yeah!
birthday yeah yeah yeah yeah well it is in my own very own shadow the clever little red cloak you still follow me around trying to pinch away some of my good goodies i sniff out oh my god i basically fucking gave you a retirement plan with my existence you mistake my intent ma'am somewhat ungeniously yeah i know the pilgrims of the settlement below were worried by your long absence it was on their behalf that tracked you again that so what a worrying bunch of busy bodies they are i'm still okay that is not true we all saw what i did that is not fucking true and yet craft is a one thing that remained in their thoughts so i don't expect of that and i can't deny that you two have done me a good turn once more the awful flock almost had me truth be told and i still have to wonder your intentions dear one but bless you all the same She's a strong,
independent woman.
She's a fucking grandma.
We gotta take her back to her time at home.
There's like those grannies that have fucking escaped.
Now why don't you hurry back to shrine and let them all know what a good job you've done.
There might be a few more goodies to get up on my way back.
I don't need you linger around in the meantime.
Blessings and farewell.
Alright, at least thank God I farmed all this money.
Do.
Is there anything here?
Wait, okay, I was gonna say, how do I get back up?
Back to the five.
Alright, this way.
Wee!
God, I'm like a little scared.
I'm gonna actually run into something.
Alright, there you go.
Full HP.
Alright, we go back.
Ooh, the five!
Wait, Ashken!
I once forgot about this elevator.
Let's just activate that.
just for just for the sake of it i have so much money i might as well doesn't hurt
oh it's just up um let's just get him down here first there you go he he doesn't deserve to live his life ends by my hand there you go it was what fate wanted it's up here There we go.
We got the elevator.
That was like $900.
He was just chilling.
Um, it was self-defense.
Just because he was a child.
Doesn't mean I can't self-defense myself.
God, just like, just like blind people.
If it hit first, I will defend myself.
And him dying is his own fault.
It's not my fault he died.
I dropped kicked him in self-defense.
You should have been so fucking weak.
If he wanted to hit me, he should have been prepared.
He should have known the consequences.
It was a good deed you did up above, dear one.
Save me from those screeching flocks not seeing the like of in a long, long time.
time i return with all sorts of new goodies too let's see if anything a scavenge will fit your fancy all right this is what we needed okay this was not what we oh wait no we need to spoil all right now i'm pouring with one purchase i i fucking do it yay more silk with one purchase i have no money now okay um spider string hold this while ensue soon here amplify song it does send it ever planning on performing for a crowd.
What the fuck is this for?
Right now, and we're still to find a...
Oh, wait, this is like, we need that.
But what is this for?
But Toki, we got a house to build.
I'm not even gonna be in that house!
It's like my vacation home that I never go on vacation because I'm always working.
I'm always fucking slaving a way to this pilgrims.
Alright, what does this...
Oh, what the...
Oh, does enemies just sing?
I was like, please, before you kill me, can you sing for me?
Mr. McFluff begins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, have you completed the area to the right of the cylinder yet?
Because if not, I have some bad news.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Is it the fucking poison swamps?
Is it the poison swamps?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes.
Hey, guys.
Thank you.
Hey, can you please react to Tim's DM of the shooting?
She called you out on...
Yeah, I heard about that.
I saw the clip.
But yeah, I didn't read the DM because I've been so stressed out and busy.
So I haven't been replying to people and DMs.
That's why.
My manager went to tell...
Because I was like, what?
What's going on?
because it was my manager that contacted her manager about it.
And then, like, I didn't know.
So then I was like, wait, what's going on?
And then, like, my manager apologized to her manager because, like, I wasn't answering any DMs at that time.
Just because I was so...
That's why I needed that break, because I was so overworked and stressed out.
Because when I'm overworked and stressed out, yeah, they set up a play there.
You remember, like, me and Tengen had a playday set up before, like, we became friends?
That's basically what happened.
So, um, so I wasn't answering, like, any messages or DMs from anybody because I was just so exhausted.
Um, um, okay, so I completed two, what do we have to do now, chat?
What do we have to do?
Oh my god, there's two.
I already got all the fleas.
what other stuff do i have to do to get the uh get the uh um i mean how many questions do i need complete i don't even know does it tell me oh there you go all right it's time to count has anybody been counting all right i'll count it one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen eighteen 19.
20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37.
We have 37 quests.
I need Shakira.
How many more do I need?
I know.
I don't need all the fleas.
I already got them the move.
I think I got all the Wishwara quests.
Did I not?
Oh yeah, I will rip that back to 10 months.
TM soon.
Don't worry, I promise.
So then we can have her eat that shoe.
Alright, now that I'm here.
Why is this bell heart?
Okay, we're gonna go this way.
Bell heart.
I need one more map to lead to another quest.
Okay.
Wait, where does Shakira live?
Where does she live?
Okay, these are just things from my house.
I am Lord.
La la la.
Where does she live?
Top right of Bellheart.
What?
What the fuck does she live?
Nobody here.
Hello?
Oh, middle, right.
Oh, there she...
Okay, there...
She was not here.
Guys, she doesn't live here.
Oh.
Oh, I forgot.
Ring, ring, ring, Shakira.
Oh, shit, Shakira.
Okay, hello.
I have mapping supplies still.
You will give you a carrot.
Oh, she doesn't have it.
Guys, she doesn't have it.
have it.
Chat.
She's like, that's what the bell's for.
What do you think was going to happen?
Yeah, they're in the petrified ducks right now.
Okay, I don't have...
There is one to bio water.
Oh my God.
I don't even remember how to get there.
How do we get to the bio water?
What did I do?
I don't remember.
See if we You're all set.
Now you get to have the last map from Shakira and Belhart.
Then go back to Belhart Forest.
The last quest once you get the quest.
Rescue, thank you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Liam, thank you, the super chat.
You need to my memory.
The fleas to be in the purgified ducks.
You need to do Shakira's quest, which means you need every map.
Alright.
The Sinner's Road.
Okay, here.
Was it here?
How the fuck do I get there?
Sinner's Road?
Like, dear?
Dude.
Really?
This is where they live?
And then I go up?
Alright.
Time to sin yet again.
This is why I never got raptured.
This is...
This is why.
Uh...
Oh my god, I have to...
Okay, I have to go from gray more.
Gray more up.
Oh my god.
Just back to sinning, I go.
No way.
No, can't help it.
Okay, gray more.
Wait, there was a citadel route, right?
Like, could I've just...
Like, could I've just done it for the...
Citadel route?
Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say it.
I did the citadel route.
Why the fuck would I make this harder for myself?
Yeah, from the little secret vault I Wait, this is not the right way.
I'm so lost.
I was just like, no, wait, this is not the wrong area.
Alright, it's this way.
I have a map, but yet somehow I'm still lost.
I don't know how.
It's time to go back to hell.
I'm gonna fall a little bit.
Oh shit!
God damn it, I thought that was the way.
Because I was like, why the fuck would it curb?
Alright.
And then...
Where am I?
Oh, fuck.
I'm so lost.
Alright, this way.
It's been a while since we've done this.
Oh, wait, there's...
Okay, elevated.
Wrong way.
How is this the wrong way?
Is this not the way back to sinners road?
Not back to sin?
Wait, how am I the wrong way?
Oh my god, I wish I have a map in the goddamn Oregon.
That's the right, oh my god, go back.
No, I did it, I did it.
Chat, please.
You're pulling me left to right.
There you go.
Oh, fuck, I thought it was more down.
Okay, now it's down.
Okay, and then we go...
Actually, let's get the chair real quick.
Before we do this.
We...
Okay, and then we go this way.
Oh, go, right?
Once I'm outside?
Oh, now you go right.
Okay.
Why am I here?
Guys, why am I here?
Um...
Alright, I guess I'll... Let me get some maggots in my body, real quick let me i never opened it all right it's fine it's fine i didn't need that silk anyway let me have a let me get some maggots in my body real quick eating my flesh it's okay i didn't like my flesh anyway i'm yam yam i didn't need my silk anyway guys it's okay that's how we fix the plague remember wait no those are leeches no actually no that's how they did it too back then.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Well, that's where I died too.
But not only did they use maggots.
But they also...
Not only did they use leeches.
But they also used maggots to eat off the dead skin.
Because they're like, That will help, surely.
That will fix everything.
Keep forgetting what this was like.
I keep forgetting what I had to do to get up here.
It's I gotta get rid of the dead skin anyway.
Alright, I don't know if I'll make it now because I sort of brute-force this, but well, let's see.
We'll just see.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Okay, then we just go right side.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna seal this.
Oh my god, I forgot they do too!
No!
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh, please.
Oh, my God.
This is so bad.
Oh.
I forgot.
I went to the bench.
No.
I forgot this.
It's okay.
I remember what to do.
I remember.
Because I was warm up.
It was warm up, everyone.
I was just warming up, guys.
Okay.
It's okay.
Now, now, now that I know the pathway, I know the pathway now, so it's fine.
It'll be okay now.
I know where to go.
See it?
Look at that.
So smooth.
So very smooth.
Okay.
There we go.
See, look at that.
So smooth.
I told you guys.
I figured it out.
Okay, now I remember.
Dog is there.
Careful about that dog.
All right.
We just keep going, right?
Just keep on swimming.
You know what they say.
There we go.
See, it's that easy.
It's okay.
We don't need that bench.
it.
Okay.
Guys, we'll be fine.
We don't need the bench.
See, look at that.
We're so okay.
Oh, we're so fine.
What's this?
Excuse me.
Why is he still here?
Oh my god.
I tried to play a song.
It's okay.
We'll just do this.
Oh, okay.
I thought you'd be like Okay, I knew God damn it, it was the wrong way It was the fucking curse It's the wrong way It's okay, I got a key It's okay I got a key Look, he threatened me with a knife So that means I can also Threaten him with seven knives It's just a way of the law That's how it works Okay,
I got a shard, but...
If he threatens me with one knife, I am legally allowed to throw seven knives at him.
Break the wall?
Which wall?
There were so many walls, guys.
Yeah, be fair.
Oh, where I got the item.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, yeah, there's a little crack.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
There's foul water.
Poison swamp, my beloved.
But...
Okay, I gotta make sure they don't roll into the swamp.
I am so sad.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I should have put the mat.
I should have wore the re- God!
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, give me a...
I know there's something over there!
Oh, fuck it.
I'll figure it out later.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I could have just done this.
Oh, my god.
No, there's so many.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, there was nothing.
Oh, my god.
Got poison creatures.
Okay.
Run.
Yeah, I have the anti-magic charm, but I need to get to it.
No!
I need to find a bench first.
I need to get through hell.
Oh my god, please leave me alone.
I paid my taxes.
I deserve better.
Oh my god, because I fucked the course you're here.
I'd pay my government fees.
I don't even know where the bench is.
I know.
I know fees.
Oh my god!
That's it.
Put chainsaw!
Chain saw!
There we go.
Oh!
I don't need more of you because I already got the amount I needed, but whatever.
The thing is, technically I don't even need to save him.
Because I already got the required amount.
There was already enough kids that I saved.
Are they all jumping away?
Eventually I'll find the bench.
I just want to get that out of the way.
Jesus, I don't like how they're all like watching.
It's creepy.
Wait, there's something above me.
I'm gonna check that out.
Oh, there he is.
Bro, it's a little creepy that you're just watching me like that.
I don't like it.
Oh, nice.
Lucky roll.
It's my lucky day.
I don't know if I should go up or left.
I can't believe.
Hell.
Surprise all.
You'll want to do it.
We'll do it later.
It's not today.
Wait, why did it make me go here?
What is over here?
Oh, but Zian, they give us super chat.
They give us super chat.
Is there anything here?
Or is that just bait?
Nothing?
Why the fuck?
Okay, it was just bait.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
At least I got enough.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's nothing here.
It was just all bait.
Oh, wait, he lives.
Okay, this was literally just here for...
Oh, my God.
No, don't do this to me.
All right.
Oh, my God.
No!
There's Shakira.
There she is.
Please tell me...
Please tell me she has...
She has, like, a chair for me.
Shakira you have a chair
She doesn't have a chair.
She doesn't have a chair Your shell is ridden with those gruesome maggots.
It was a foolish choice of yours.
This I wasn't I wasn't out of choice This by not means this I know like even even even the Hornet agrees like I didn't do this out of choice Shakira for now I think it's best you remain at limb's length.
I should not be a by this infection lung by silk or by rest I shall soon find myself cleansed.
All right Got the map It's all right the still the maggots is truly eating me from the inside, but that's okay now I know where the bet nope Nope, I don't know where the bench is.
I still I Still don't know where it is All right Oh, cello Oh, cello Okay, down.
What was it?
Down left?
Alright.
Is there anything else important here that I should be aware of?
Top left?
Wait, where?
Up?
Oh my god.
I heard down left first.
Okay.
Okay, where is that bench?
Yeah?
Where is it?
Down left.
Guys, guys, please.
Where is it?
Here?
Here.
Down left.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, wait.
There's a station.
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's a station.
There is hope.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Get your ass out of here.
Alright, we go this way.
And then we go down.
And we still go down.
That's pretty cool, huh?
No.
You can't tell.
This place has not been maintained in a long ass time.
Is this where the tram station is?
Why the fuck did the tram station, okay, too far down?
Yeah, I was gonna say, where the fuck is the tram station?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, there we go.
I knew getting the money was a good idea.
Is this the bench?
What is this?
What?
This is the...
Oh, this is the tram, right?
Yeah, this is the tram.
I just noticed that bells...
He did it.
Thank God.
Thank God I farmed off stream.
Look at that.
Now I can consensually go to bad water whenever...
Alright, we did it.
the map now what do we do chat you know what oh do we need we need to grab the how many fleas am i missing anyway one oh there was more two three oh god three okay bell heart first to get the quest okay we'll get the quest then god i have a craving for jolly bees I don't know why.
I really want the spaghetti and the chicken.
I really want jolly bees.
I love jolly bees.
I love the sweet pasta.
The sweet spaghetti.
Oh yeah, Shakira.
La la la la.
I am lord.
La la la.
What?
She took away the bell.
Wait, how about...
Oh, it's on the quest board.
Okay, I'm gonna be like, how do I like it?
Tell her to get over it.
Okay, child wielding needle.
I've caught fresh scent on my master in those stricken swamps.
Besides, ask you now to follow me.
Alright, time to go through the swamp.
And then she was like, enough.
I revoke your privilege to ring the bell.
Best boss fight in the game coming up in that area.
Yes, it is required.
I don't know if you're lying to me.
That's the thing.
It's not what everyone likes to say.
They'll be like, no, it's definitely required.
And then I find out it's not.
Guys, not even like guys, bosses you want me to fight doesn't mean it's required.
That's all I'm saying.
Okay.
We don't need a poison.
It is required.
Alright.
I'm gonna fix the map.
Get rid of all of these.
Okay, where do we go?
Do we just go up?
It actually is required.
Okay, I'll choose.
to believe, you guys.
I'll choose to hope.
Yeah, it is required for me.
We're going up, up, up in the moment.
Bada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada, nada.
Oh, wait, this is not the right area.
You know what's funny?
For those who don't know, Fortnite, announced the collab with um kpop demon hunter with no jam tracks like the whole the whole movie oh my god it's fine i don't have maggots anyway the whole movie is about singing but they didn't even include any of the music other than for the um other than for uh one of the what was it the the shield thing which i thought was hilarious because i was like the whole it's a fucking musical but yet you can't jam to it yeah Yeah,
none of the songs are...
Only Golden is in the...
Is in Fortnite.
Oh, he's not...
She's not here anymore.
And no skins.
They don't deserve skins.
The guys don't...
Alright.
Other than the main evil bad guy.
Like...
The other male characters have like no sustenance.
They're literally...
Holy shit.
Like...
They're not even characters.
Oh, there it is.
What?
But I just thought it was so funny that...
Oh my god, where is she going?
That the only song they have in there was Golden, and it's when you use an item in the game to access it.
You're just jealous that they're...
Popular.
Wait, what was her bad name again?
I don't even remember.
Saja Boys, yeah.
You're just a Saja Boy anti.
You're a hater.
You're right.
You're so right.
Jesus, these guys are very annoying.
Oh my god!
What?
It did so much damage.
It freaked me out.
It like actually me like hesitate let's
see it guys guys i don't even remember what um oh my god this might be over for me what even is like the name of the band the main girls the band i just call them kpop demon hunters that's i don't even remember what their actual names are the huntrix oh yeah it's the huntrix
Okay, now I remember.
They were just called them K-pop demon hunters.
I need to reload.
That's how little I pay attention.
Like, it was a good movie.
I think I'm the one of the rare people that only watched it once.
I mean, I listened to the songs, like, several times, but, like, I don't think I listened to them enough to...
enough compared to the others.
I already forgot how to get there Yeah
Bro even Okay you know what's fucked up Actual kpop fans actually don't like Not actual sorry A lot of kpop fans don't like Don't like kpop demon hunters Because their views are like Getting in the way of their Of their kpop Oshis What are they called when you Like because I know like Oshing is like a Japanese hearing,
but what is it called when you like a, you like a, one of the K-pop bands?
It's actually crazy.
Like they got mad.
Am I going the right way?
Sand.
Yeah, sorry.
The K-pop stands.
Yeah, they got mad at K-pop demon hunters because you're like, oh man, it's actually crazy.
You're like, uh, oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
I'm actually, oh my god, in time.
Thank god.
Okay.
They were like, Where is the bench, by the way, before I...
I'm so scared.
I need to know where's the bench.
Because they're like, how dare these virtual...
It's like, you know, like they're like, oh, they're virtual.
They're not real.
You know, like the whole YouTuber argument delay.
How dare...
Up left?
Oh, they're like, how dare...
They're not even real.
How dare they hit number one?
They're replacing my...
Jesus Christ.
I hate these guys.
I hate these guys so much.
Replacing, like, real talent.
I'm like, what?
What the fuck is wrong with you guys?
But that's only for the crazy stands.
Because obviously not all K-pop stands are like that.
People were just like, don't trust the bed, the sand.
Yeah, but the real people still sang that song.
So, like, a lot of K-pop stands don't like K-pop Demon Hunter, which is fucking crazy.
I mean, to be fair, K-pop Demon Hunter is, like, unrealistic portrayal of K-pop in general.
Because I'm like, there's no way they let these girls eat that much.
I'm just like, I know that's really fucked up for me to say.
You know, it's true.
I was like, damn.
That manager is too nice.
Also, the manager being so nice, too.
Is it real?
I don't know.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
Guys, it wasn't real.
I had a feeling it was never real.
That's why you guys all kept telling me go to the bench.
I knew it wasn't real.
I knew I should never hope in this world.
Now it's on- okay, where is Shakira?
Where is Shakira?
Is it up top?
Wait, where...
How did I get up top?
Go back down and right?
You see that thing up there?
How the fuck do I get that?
Is there no way to get up there?
Oh, I have to go right.
Oh my god, that fucking hits me.
Life is so cruel.
Nero, thank you.
It was a super chat-thinking thing.
Yeah, also the fact that the manager is that nice and...
That's crazy.
And also the fact that like the fans are okay, but what's her name?
Rooney?
Oh my god, fuck you!
You know, they're- oh my god, I'm too so distracted.
You know how Rooney- there was like that moment where like, you're- the fans are like, oh my god, I totally ship you with...
um oh my god i'm going in here with zero hp i'm
but like when they're like oh my god it's okay i love shipping you with the other male male k-pop i was like that is not true that is not true bro these they'll eat you alive if they find out you're dating anyone i was like did no one remember
Open map.
I am opening map.
I'm opening.
Oh my god.
Oh!
It explodes!
It fucking explodes.
Of course it explodes.
I forgot that it explodes, guys.
Okay, now I need to remember how to get back there.
Okay.
It explodes.
Yeah, life likes to play funny tricks on you sometimes.
Oh my god.
Get out of here!
Please, leave me alone!
Leave me alone!
There we go.
I'm enjoying my run back right now.
Other than that, Those are my- It's not supposed to be realistic because they are hunting demons, but I was just like...
I just thought, like, that's funny.
It's like the idealized version of what they want K-pop to be like.
K-pop stands will always scare me.
Let's see if...
Am I going the right?
Wait, okay, it's the right side.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Go this way.
Wait, I don't...
Oh, it's up and up.
Oh my god, please.
Alright.
Up we go.
And then up we go.
then.
And then guess what, guys?
We still keep going up.
Oh my god, I went the wrong.
It's the wrong up.
And then we go left.
We go left.
And then I have to go through this hell again.
Oh my god!
What?
That's it.
I'm swimming.
You win.
I'll just swim.
You fucking!
guys i didn't have that much money right it's okay i didn't have that much money on me i you spent it all it's okay it's okay i i remember spending it all okay this uh fucking area sucks so much oh now i get lucky mother the night to get like
Okay, who needs money anyway, guys?
Who needs it?
Oh my, it's fine.
That's fine.
I can take a little more.
It's fine.
Yes, I might not have money anymore.
But I already spent...
I already spent all the money.
It's okay.
Oh, come on.
Not okay.
I'm actually not okay.
I fucked up.
There you go.
Okay, what do you say?
Uh, Jokia, don't like seeing you suffer.
There's a chair wildly close to the end, and you can get your cocoon back with the stuff where I'm seeing you in the super chat, Odin.
Then you think, like, at the end of this area, where I died, is that it?
This is the place where I died?
The very unfortunate place.
I hate this area.
This is why I kept this last.
Okay.
That's fine.
The bottom right corner of that room?
What room here?
Is that... Is that... I swear to God.
Is that where the chair is?
I swear to fucking God.
No!
okay oh the flee room here oh my god i could go up from here it's fine
life is just likes to be very silly with me
it's already too late for me the doctor said it was terminal it's already too late for me swim oh my god okay yeah i think i agree i think kpop demon hunter was a good film it is a good film
okay where do i go after that i'm pausing it because i don't trust myself wait there's something over here no no that was the bait area god damn it that was the bait area I'll do it this way.
I need the extra money.
I'm already so poor.
Alright, back to whatever this was that we never got to find out.
He's like, I hit.
By these fuckers.
Okay, please!
I'm fucking trying to find my friend.
friend please oh my god oh my god he was trying to bait me into oh my god and he did it he did it he dog okay okay we're okay
we're okay okay i think god thank god oh fucking okay we're good We're okay
I don't even know where I passed the bench I don't know Could it be down
Oh my god please Where could this bench be
Oh was it down there I hate him I hate him
here oh my god please there was nothing here there was nothing here oh it's here oh my god it was here all along i
went the wrong way no don't say that i'm literally living by the one hp in the dream and hope that i will find a bench Guys, this does not look bench like Guys
This does not look like there'd be a Oh my god, there is a chair Oh my god, I can't believe it There is a chair amidst all these fucking bodies That's crazy Their shells are ours, their solar ours are hated Oh, that's me, our hate is forever That's me That truly looked like absolute hell.
Burnies.
I knew there was something in those bodies.
I fucking knew it.
Does that mean there's bodies in here too?
Give me your stuff.
I'm here to rob you.
Why the fuck did you die with nothing?
Maybe there's stuff.
here okay they're pilgrims oh they don't they didn't die with anything now they'll never rest all right now that we got it would i repair my reef i did right i did how did you die poor how would i rob you now all right so where is shakira where is shakira guys is it all the way here
Is it all over here?
Can I go back from here?
I don't even know Do I have to do the do I have to do the climb again or can I go back from here?
Can I?
Okay, just want me sure.
I don't want to waste my time Doing like the run back
Yeah, yeah, I can you die It's gonna be like I swear to God I have to do the goddamn run back.
I swear to God
Okay, and then...
Okay, it's up top.
There you go.
And then it was this way.
Okay, he should have died from that, too.
Alright, tracking time.
Alright, Shakira.
I'm coming for you.
Don't worry.
I'll be your hero.
Oh my.
God please I know you didn't ask for it but I'm gonna do it anyway oh my god I have to do this jump again wait there's something here oh she just goes that way but where where does this way go is this where oh what's over here oh my god what's over here though I'm oh my god it's just more traps Is something special?
Alright, I leave.
Every time you say that, I don't trust it.
Because I think my definition of special is different from your definition of what special is.
Oh?
Shakira?
Did you hear that Zootopia 2 is coming up?
Ole ole?
Shakira?
Are you excited?
Oh, hey, it's...
Oh, hey, look, I'm getting a shower, too.
Oh, it's your master.
She looks very alive.
Oh, Shanka, Hornet.
Really, needle.
But that is your name, isn't it not?
I've heard it spoken in this land with reverence.
I hope you would accept my summon in these moments.
One is good, but two is best.
That's fine.
Oh, not denying that wish, Shakira.
A somber ceremony seemed likely at this trail's end.
And I am sadly proved correct.
The Sten is your master?
The fiercest of my tribe.
Here she lies.
I called her master true, but she was mother just as much.
More by far than a bug who bore me.
Among the many marvels of this kingdom, she found a fine place to meet her end.
Ended by age.
My tribe will call that chief.
How dare she live a happy and fulfilling life?
If I try it, if I see Yoni's training, unbeaten.
Even as a shallow betrayer, she walks this kingdom of breath.
Does her trail fall that allow me to share witness to its dignity?
Yes, she's not going to fall, hallowed now.
You two have journeyed these many paths as my master before us.
Join me now for a song sending.
Yonusha.
For shame.
Die young.
Live fast and die young, apparently.
Yeah, I was gonna say, she died undefeated.
Is that not what you want?
I feel like that's a greater honor.
Wish granted.
For sharing this moment, I shall have you accept the gift, one I had believed I would never pass.
You take these rings and the learnings to make more.
There are belts of a clever method devised by my master, and will crush hard this kingdom's toughest shell.
Use them, and she is remembered.
My thanks, Shakira.
Gain a tool so defined by its owner, I am much grateful.
They shall prove a great aid on my own journey.
Yay!
Oh, I got her throwing wings.
rings.
Oh, I heard that.
Oh, I can't flip it.
Okay, I did it.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I recommend finishing bywater sooner than later.
The top part?
Okay.
I don't even know technically how to get which part.
This part?
Wait, but how do I like this part?
How do I even get there?
Yeah, it has a special taunt.
I just realized you can taunt in this game.
See?
that's me like saying fuck you and silk star
more than and then the one who brought down so many characters in this yeah everybody here has like mommy and daddy issues but like i'm not surprised because like in bug world like usually you know the bug when the mom the mom usually gets eaten by its children or like um or like they just abandoned them so i'm not surprised that they all have mommy and daddy issues.
Because that's the way of the bug.
It's a bug's life, exactly.
So how do we get to up here?
It's the circle of life.
Oh, just go left.
Oh, here, right?
A little intermission that I took earlier.
Oh.
A fucking course.
A fucking course that hits me still.
I want to grab this for extra silk later.
God, I hate this world.
Zoom this way?
Oh, there it is.
Where the fuck do I get to the fleas?
Wait, did I miss the flea?
Oh my god.
Did I miss the fleet?
But what about the fleet?
Do we not care about...
Oh!
It's in the secret room.
Are you guys taking me to a boss fight?
I'm not okay.
I'm not.
Okay, you guys were you guys were okay let me redo my let me i guess redo everything let me just because i don't think chainsaw works here all right that's fine all right let's you know what no we gotta try it up but the bomb is better okay all right so where is the fleet where do i get the fleet it's fine that's fine tough love Love.
So how do I get the fleet?
Up a bit and then left.
Don't worry, this is...
I don't know.
I feel like I don't believe you guys.
Top, left, and room above?
What?
Outside.
Okay, we're gonna look at the map together.
Guys, okay.
Where?
Where is it?
Let's look at this together.
Leave bench area, then go left.
Okay.
Like here?
Or here?
One or two?
Two?
Here.
Okay.
Right of two.
Here?
Here.
I know, but it's secret.
It's a secret area!
One.
Okay, one, two.
Okay.
Because I see the fleet.
I just know it's a secret area.
So I need to remember nowhere to access it in the secret area.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I hate all of you.
You guys all don't deserve to live.
Oh my god, there it is.
Oh my god, a fucking chorus.
Get out of here.
Oh!
Alright, I freed him.
I freed the child.
Oh my, oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of this personal hell.
I remember how to...
I don't remember.
a bumper.
Try to remember how to get there.
I'm running in circles.
I'm activating every fucking trap.
Oh my god.
Of course it falls down.
Fucking course he came back.
Wait, why the fuck?
Oh my god.
It's to the right.
I'm so stupid.
I'm...
Oh my god.
I'm so stupid.
I didn't realize I had to go right.
It just all blurs together.
Everything looks the same in this world.
In bio water.
It truly is the poison swamp.
It all looks the same.
Oh my god, I'm really missing one more hit.
Are you saying that?
serious i ran out i ran out of are you where did he come from i thought i killed you i thought he killed you are
you fucking that's fine that's not fine it's not fine anymore
oh my god he killed this guy i need to kill him i can't do this run back because of him being alive
i don't remember like is it here I didn't say yes, it was here.
I'm going in with 0 HP, too.
This fucking sucks.
That's fine.
It can take what I don't have anymore.
Oh my god, why did I go here?
Why did I go here, too?
What is wrong with me?
Surely this path would be easier.
Alright.
We...
Just flying over as much as I can.
Alright, back to hell, I guess.
Alright.
My guy.
I hate these guys so much.
There we go.
We got one.
I just hate them.
I hate them so much.
Holy shit Oh, more Oh, never seen you before Oh, now you throw it That down That's cool That's fine You know what?
Oh my god, wait What?
Oh, because it's water That makes sense
Hello Like, I'm not I'm not fine with you.
I was gonna say I'm fine with these guys.
Never mind.
I'm not.
Twin.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I can't actually.
Okay.
Where's the other guy?
I'll just swim here.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I used it all.
My reef, my reef fish broke.
Oh, fucking curse.
I was
like, this is too easy.
This is too easy.
Thank you.
A fucking curse there was more.
I had a feeling.
Oh, there you go.
There goes.
There we go.
I'm about to have such a good...
It's like, I...
Okay, I shouldn't have died there, but I was just not okay anymore.
I want you guys to know I was...
I was not okay anymore.
I was like...
this is over for me.
I don't care.
I don't know what to use.
Are you a string shard?
Alright.
Because I have to do the gauntlet again, right?
Okay, let me...
I'm not comfortable enough to get rid of my compass to do this run back.
Okay, I'll change it.
I'm actually, I'm not comfortable enough.
Um, I mean, I can try.
I'll try.
Oops, not that.
What did I get rid of?
Oh, this one.
I'll try.
We'll try it.
Slow and steady.
Oh my god.
Absolutely hell.
is this way oh my god I love they're so generous to me
wow this game is so generous it's so wonderful they treat me so well I should have changed you know what you're right I should have changed my I should have change my crest just for these guys.
Like, these fuckers alone.
I'm not okay right now.
Alright, if I die again, I'll change my crest, because I'm not okay about this.
Oh, my God.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I am mine.
I wasn't even supposed to get it that way.
I went too far.
It's like, yeah, I'm already broke.
Cat.
You would have just taken nothing from me.
That's fine.
I already have nothing in my name.
Oh.
Hello.
I'm ready.
I'm not.
But like...
Oh my god.
Okay, I wanted to try this.
Okay, this sucks.
This actually sucks.
Oh my god, someone please stop them.
I can't.
I give up.
I give up already.
Get over here.
I'm ready.
Last hope.
Okay.
All right.
I have an idea of what to use.
get rid of this because that shit was garbage and then put that in again and then um I don't have spike traps um we'll deal ah fuck yeah I don't know we'll do this and then we're changing actually oh wait we're changing our what am I doing we're not even gonna use we'll change your crest is this is it wonder yeah Yeah,
it's Wonder.
Okay.
Dirt storm.
The grippers.
And then we get...
Okay, we can only have one tool.
And I'm just gonna use... I'm gonna try this.
Ah!
Maybe boomerang?
We'll try boomerang.
And then...
There we go.
Equip that lawn claw.
Wait, I have one more slot.
I forgot about that.
Wait, no, we don't need that.
Okay, now we just have an extra thing that we don't fucking...
I don't fucking care.
The long claw.
We need a long claw.
But what about the maggots?
I like the quick heal.
The quick heal has been...
It's fine.
We'll do the quick heal.
We'll try this.
The quick heal has...
came in clutch way too many times for me.
We'll be fine.
We'll be so safe.
Don't worry.
Trust me.
Oh my god, that felt a lot easier now.
I didn't like to do this before.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Don't worry, we're fine.
Okay, starting now.
Starting, starting now.
We're fine.
Look, something happened to me.
Okay.
Oh my god, I didn't even see this guy.
Starting now.
It's now.
This is when things will be okay.
See?
Starting, I told you.
Starting now.
I could just run past this.
Fuck it.
Just run past it.
Alright.
We made it.
I think this run back fucking sucks, but we made it.
We fucking made it.
Okay, there we go.
We got one.
Are you fucking kidding me?
There we go.
We got two.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, that felt...
That definitely felt a lot easier.
I'm not gonna lie!
There we go.
Oh my god, I almost forgot about this.
Oh!
You know what?
Okay.
Oh my god, you're right, my raid has already broke, almost broken.
Whoopsie.
Ah!
Get away from me!
Please!
The fact that I have to do this and then fight that boss is tilting.
Come on, this is worth it.
Okay, that's fine.
When... okay, I heard there is a trick to this.
And I'm gonna abuse it.
I remember, I saw a video of this fight.
Because they like...
This is worth it.
I remember now.
I was like, wait, I remember.
I saw a video of this.
Okay.
Eat me!
Give me, give me my silk!
Give me my silk!
That's okay, right?
That won't touch me, right?
Oh shit, he doesn't want to...
He's like, you know what, maybe not.
Oh god, oh god, okay.
Four!
Oh my god, he doesn't like the taste, apparently.
Okay, now you can eat me.
That's right!
Oh shit, he's mad!
Oh shit, what?
Oh!
I was like what the fuck was that I don't taste that bad I thought I was pretty nutritious bugs are very good for nutritious value why would he spit me out like that or eat me bro I don't understand I thought I That was very nutritious for that Mia.
He cast fireball.
Yeah, why does he have a sword?
We all know they don't have swords.
Magic users don't have swords.
That's fucking weird.
Oh my god, used my luck on you as one guy.
Very good use of my lucky roll.
There you go.
Oh my god, they regenerate?
Wait, what the fuck?
I didn't know that.
Where did he come from?
Okay, there you go.
Thank you for the rain, Meryl.
Thank you, thank you.
We have a good stream.
Thank you, fucker.
Okay, thank you so much.
Like this, I'm just grabbing.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Where did he come from?
Where did all these guys come from?
Oh my god, that's so far up too.
Oh my god, I'm fucking cursed.
Oh my god, please.
There we go.
We got one of them.
I know I got to just stand underneath them.
There we go.
It's fine.
One.
There are three hits, so it's okay.
Okay, that's a waste on my reef, but I'm also like, I don't care.
I don't care.
Jesus Christ, I hate these guys so much.
Oh, wow.
It's fine.
Getting the lucky road here, I'm okay with.
I'm honestly okay with that.
Alright, nice.
Nice three hits.
Can't catch me.
I'm in the corner.
It's fine.
Jesus Christ.
It's not fine.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
There we go.
All right.
It's time for war.
It's war time.
Oh, I thought I could like...
Oh, what?
Are you serious?
Are you...
Ah, dang it!
What happened before?
Oh my god, he knows.
He knows my plan.
He knows.
He won't give me the satisfaction.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Give me out of here.
There we go He was like I won't give you the satisfaction Oh shit
Are you serious fuck off My god.
Oh, this is bad I should have healed He just jumped into his mouth Okay I realized Reef is not in You're right guys Let's just put the log Glot in I forgot he does Two damage I don't think we need I don't think we need it I self-sabotage myself I was like That's enough Wait Fuck Wait I forgot Never mind I should have.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
I forgot.
I actually...
It's fine.
I forgot to get there.
I have to take...
I have to swim.
What did we learn?
Absolutely nothing.
It wins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Apparently I didn't learn my lesson at all.
There we go.
Oh, didn't matter.
He's having to get...
Oh my god, I thought I was already there.
Because, of course, of course it's not that...
There we go.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Alright.
I just gotta make sure that he doesn't show up.
Woo-hoo!
Dodged.
Alright, back to hell.
Grab...
Oh my god.
I'll get the maggots off me first.
Okay, I know it's three hits.
Shaw.
How dare you say Shaw.
In my presence.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm just through forcing him so I'm so over these guys there you go here we go
oh yes stay in the corner that is my strat the most clever of strats in this in this game.
Surely staying in the corner won't hurt me, right?
Shadame!
Don't worry, the corner will never do me wrong.
The corner strat never fails, guys.
Right?
It'll be fine.
Oh my god, it'll be fine.
Oh my god!
We're fine starting now, Isaac.
Charlemagne.
Okay.
I live in this is my corner.
It's a very nice corner.
Alright, surely he'll...
Okay.
Yeah, I got one hit.
Do you guys see that?
The one hit?
Ah, you fucker!
Oh, already?
Oh my!
What?
Nice, okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, how did he do so much?
Oh my god!
We know for me!
Guys, it was not a good idea to just stand in front and like just take it off.
And he took it clearly.
Okay, I found out that it might not have been a good idea to like just let him do that.
That might have been a little bit of a mistake.
But now I know.
Now I know.
I learned from my mistake.
See, guys, I can learn.
Oh, shit!
I can learn.
Like I said, I can learn, surprisingly.
Okay, this is a risk I'll take.
There we go.
I swear to God, am I...
died in his stomach i swear to god this was the risk i was willing to take we did it we did it everyone oh oh door open did we not oh chair oh hey nice oh we free the voice chat works Who would have thought?
Oh my god, this area fucking sucked.
Alright, back to...
Back to this one.
We go.
Higher risk, higher reward.
Not trapped!
Alright, get this shit out of here.
Give me back my poison.
Alright, we're fine.
Yeah, we did it.
Alright, so this guy was part of the main quest, right?
I got the Seeker Soul.
What is that?
Oh, was it bad that I broke that?
It was broken when I was already here.
It was, I swear to God.
It was already broken.
Was that Snail's corpse?
I didn't even notice.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, now we're here.
I was, like, wondering how we could get to this area.
Wait, what?
Where is this place?
Oh, putrefied ducks.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's not dad.
That's someone else's dog.
That's parking.
There's two dogs barking outside my apartment right now.
Not my dog.
Not my dog, not my problem.
But where do I go from here?
Back to the song claim?
Anyway, I'll get rid of these.
They're like, okay, Preachified Ducks is the fastest, right?
Yeah, it is.
Alright.
I was trying to see which way was fastest.
Get out of this hellhole.
I can't believe I...
Oh!
Oh wait, I need to...
needed to wait what oh no it's right side I did not I forgot all about these fuckers wait where the fuck is the is it not here oh it is I just thought it was a wall you will not be missed nope it's this way it's cool that I left that area last truly was hell going through that trauma oh my got you again.
There we go.
There is justice in this world.
By the way, that whole boss fight and upper bywater was skippable with what the fuck do you mean?
What the fuck is vault vessel?
What this?
How is this skippable?
What the fuck do you mean?
Mr. McLaughlin can say you in a super chat thank you thank you what does that even mean do you skip something like this hey where do we go again sorry the the shock of it learning it was skippable threw me off oh it's technically a bug oh it's a sequence break
Okay, so I have to go to the grand bell wave.
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Boar's chat works.
Alright.
This way.
Don't play with my heart like that.
I don't know why they're barking.
Maybe they don't like my stream.
Send her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
How long?
your name yet i didn't realize your name could get that long oh yes what is it don't think i ain't seen it seen it bell ringer a whole lot of helping you've been up to both here and down below so strange a mantle you're taking for yourself seeing all of them bugs saved and wishes promised find it strange sir i found some solace in the service and the rewards received have proven a boon in my journey not a miss i but in your place now is it i see well what you are weaver and more it's below your sister station we know calm and short men for caring on this low flow just because i'm royalty dosh i mean i don't care i gotta look after my people you know i could say the same for you who still chooses to remain caled we continue to pose as only a simple pilgrim don't you think it's past time you cease your performance leave off old one permit a bug their small disguise it's been a pleasant thing to play simple and I weren't calling for a change even if you seemed insistent on bringing it
change was unavoidable sir whether I arrived or not the monarch stares his threads stretched far my presence only accelerated the inevitable so what you're hoping for a planning the usurp that perch above us all as queen fill up your our hopes only to string us all in your own beastly web such is the way of the weavers and gods of both but i already spoke what do i do i spoke to him but he doesn't care he just was like all right what did i get
this what do i do oh talk to him what i do you and her who waits up there that feeding meaning won't hold forever ready to make your play the else one ruler and her place.
Anath did not.
Some part of me desires the outcome.
Oh, damn!
She's a domi-mommy.
Darnas, it seems, is baked deep in my blood.
I still no doubt for the one up top.
And yet another part resists, a part over time I find myself siding with, more.
That part wishes not to claim a monarch's mantle.
Rather, it would see my freedom regained, and this kingdom's bug unshackled from their pale chains.
remarkable idea you're speaking there bell ringer a world cut free not a wish i've had much cause to hope on serious like i ain't so surprised to hear you speak it for all you're helping i've been seeing you clear still got the monarch in you all right and the glare of a weaver or the ambition that's wild different from both if you have already guessed to my desire sir or share aid in the conflict to come?
I, maybe, yes.
I can barely tell it.
But there is an idea.
One rare disgust for fear of her up there sensing the score.
You conceived a method, I take it.
A way to see a monarch removed.
It made me left free from claiming her station.
We have me and what remains of my family.
It's a trap of a sort beyond the skill of the Citadel.
One to go further than just her binding.
You'd be just a hunter to set it if you dare enough to try.
Alright, we got it.
Damn.
No wonder all her mates died.
She sucked the soul out of them.
Grab me your aid, sir.
If your trap provides a path to freedom, both for myself and your lands of bug, I may indeed choose to trigger it.
What work do you require of me now to see that your service may be?
That's my family's strength you'll need to be seeking, Bellringer.
Us three old bugs still alive.
Spread cross the kingdom.
And one poor cousin dead and drained in swamps choked rotten.
Each has power.
Raw, savage stuff for you.
They'll give it.
If for their sad fascination at the act or the thrill of deviance.
Or because they have no choice at all.
And last, as the base.
Seek a weak weapon of weaver's past.
should still be one left down there in their largest nest a snare and a set an old runo searing silk our own trap will be woven typed about it okay okay what do we okay silk we got the seeker soul hermit soul maiden soul will it show on my map okay it doesn't show on my map that's not good he doesn't know that I destroyed his corpse.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Of course, there's a fleet.
I forgot here.
Okay.
Where does he say it is?
Oh, Sabo.
Um.
Down in the moss lands.
Where the fuck is she, though?
Is it a bone grave?
Where is she?
The hermit.
Oh, the crazy one!
I remember.
It's like here.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go for a crazy one I remember
the first one I met okay after we get all the items we'll grab all the flea's too so we don't have to worry about the flea upgrade the nail upgrade later because we need a fully upgrade nail for this fuck like for this rack 3
no the old crazy lady
upgrade my quest do I have I don't know.
I feel like I haven't found enough crests.
She's like here somewhere.
Just the first one I met.
There she is.
Madam, I return seeking power to aid the construction of a trap.
I request of your sibling residing on top of the citadel.
Hanging under.
So you imagine her, I'll see you in the full time.
I know they're coming, felt it, and glad I am.
Rest on my family.
You've spent far too long.
in love or dead not me i've always been thinking it'll waste to just take what's coming what hurt when her up top wakes better to fight for freedom or go out and blaze oh yeah i got her so yoink my now oh you can upgrade or oh um not discover oh okay well just upgrade it then why have i not upgrade for my crest oh i need to find a chair I have,
like, several memory lockets.
Oh my god, this dog is yapping.
At least that stops after a while.
This dog has not stopped.
Have I unlocked everything?
Yeah, I have.
Okay, there's this one.
I need a five more crest.
Snare?
What's the snare?
what's the snare is that the oh the snare setter okay where is that oh
architect oh is it oh ask eva about it here right okay remember how to get there
oh wait it's like this way
and he's one hit right above that bench okay uh down all right
he thought he was being so clever
great fight back there by the way there's a secret ending that can only be done before act three you're interested in that jesse they give you the super chat thank you i know what it is guys I'm not doing no damage.
I'm not doing no healing.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm not strong enough.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
And you can't fool me.
I know.
I know that ending.
It's not no damage, but it's no healing.
And I think that's a little worse.
I've been up here.
Wait, what's up here?
Oh, hey.
Thank you for the...
Oh, there's the stair-setter.
Oh, that's why I need it.
Thank you for the raid.
I hope you had a great stream.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Talk to Eva.
Hello, Eva.
Lady, if in your travels you're able to further expand your nature, return to me.
What powers are possessed?
I may be able to aid you further.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
I don't have enough.
I need to...
I need to unlock one more crest or some shit.
Beam me up, Scotty.
Wow.
Yeah, I have three memory lockets, so I think...
I'm pretty sure I can unlock it.
Knock, knock.
Walk and buy a crest from the architect?
How much money do I have?
Okay, where does she live?
I forgot where she lived.
It's been a while.
Guys, do you guys remember where that lady lived?
Because I don't.
Underworks?
Here.
Where is it?
Is it here?
Where did she live?
Here?
Okay.
Here, right?
The little circles thing?
Oh!
Oh, I forgot that's the shop.
Okay, I'll just put that there just just in case.
Oh, yes, we can get the cog bug or whatever.
That's helpful.
Oh, I could have used that so long ago for boss fights.
Thank God these guys are one hit.
Also, like, where is the last last guy?
Where's his soul?
Where is his soul?
Where's the hermit's soul?
live.
Belheart?
Yeah, we have a hermit at Belheart?
Since when?
I did not notice this.
It's because he's... I just don't notice the poor.
I've been Belheart, so I just don't notice him.
I have not noticed this guy.
Where's the homeless guy?
Oh my god!
Where was this?
what the fuck where was this this entire time he was living underneath us this entire time no i never been here i didn't even realize this existed i've actually never been here guys i didn't even realize this was a place well we're gonna rob him too real quick i didn't even know there was a fucking hermit living underneath us this entire time also where am i going now Oh my god,
I don't...
Okay.
I gotta find him again.
Okay, there he is.
Hello.
What do you want, slave?
Slave?
I'm a traveler, stranger.
Not a slave.
No, I knew he was here, but I just wanted to explore more.
I'm grunk.
Exactly what a slave would say.
Be gone!
This is literally my first time I've spoken to him.
So the slave comes seeking?
heard it wishing on a world cut free yes along with my nephew up there sounds he's sunk up as simple as you fine we not provide your aid bug the trappy plans requires power and i suspect you're hoarding more than most oh no i'll give it not in the hope you'll succeed but on that there's in that there's a slim chance i give just to see that restless energy unleashed so much so Found and formed generations of it all going now waste better.
It's giving a chance to blaze All right, I got it.
What's down here?
I never been down here before Is there anything cool down here?
Oh, it's just money All right, that's cool
I mean, it's pretty cool But is there actually anything a shortcut to where There's so many paths here.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Actually, where am I?
I'm so lost.
Where did I go?
Is that Mara?
Where am I heading, George?
There was a shortcut all along.
Oh my god.
There was.
it's a marrow what the fuck oh my god that's what it was for this entire time alright now we gotta hunt okay we'll get the rest of the fleas then we'll get the architect ship and then we'll kill her again alright we need to grab where are the fleas okay we can't go to the sands of crack at least it's just like one and then we gotta go to how do we get this one though this one i don't know where's the secret passage for this is it here
which way to get to this
right under it right here
okay oh it's a parkour challenge okay what the fuck was here oh i remember all right
Just figure out how to...
Just try and figure out which way is faster.
Just go here.
Ow.
Fuck it.
Okay, we'll go from here, actually.
Oh.
That's fine.
Dodged!
And then what?
Look at this way.
Get out of here.
Get out of here, children!
Get out of there.
That's where I one-shot you now.
While you're out here being mindless pilgrims, I was out there leveling up.
Okay, we'll grab the sand thing first.
Ada!
I was studying the blade.
I already forgot where to go.
I already forgot.
Yeah, okay, where is it?
Blastic steps.
Okay, blasted steps.
Alright, here we go.
The worst part is, like, all the fleas are, like, in places where...
I don't have...
I'm pretty sure I'm missing some more fleas, too, I think.
Because I think I didn't buy all the maps.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, you should go to Greymore from Bellhop from optional Act 2 boss.
It's fun.
definition of fun might not be my definition of fun.
Darn you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have a feeling that we have two very different definitions of what fun is.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I gotta swap.
I just realized.
I gotta go back down.
I realized this is I remember you guys were like this is parkour and that's like didn't register in my head What I was like what is parkour?
What do you mean by parkour?
All right
There you go Wait do I have my compass yeah
Okay, I have my parkour set up the grippers, my, my strong-ass grippers.
Okay.
Go up.
Alright.
He's gripping that wall.
Whoops.
Get
him out of this way.
No!
My teeth scars!
Okay.
Get him out of here.
So how do I...
Guys, how do I...
get up there.
Did I just keep going, right?
I assume... Oh, it's here, right?
Is it here?
Okay.
There we go.
How do we get from across?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I think it is.
I think...
That's it.
No!
Because I didn't know!
I didn't know that's what it does!
Okay.
Now I get it, though.
It's dumb, but I get it.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I was like, where do I go?
There you go.
I hope I never see you again.
Alright.
Now on to the next one.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you All this time been changing a tie on my dad's truck had Doki as BGMS all the way did you guys make her do it avoid Yeah, no they didn't make me I consented
They didn't they didn't make me there is no required boss don't fuck with me right now I did all the bosses that I needed to do I
I offered.
I know.
How is it required?
Explain.
Yes, there is.
You should really beat this boss.
Why?
Explain.
They're all required for entertainment.
Required to have fun.
is every boss is required if you're not the coward okay where is it here is it here
does he stay dead after i kill him because i know in act three okay it makes act three easier okay top left this one here is it this one
yes okay all right okay I choose to believe you guys out of ignorance let's go
all right here I go here I go I'm heading over okay It's for your own- we're just doing it for your own good.
That's what parents tell you.
So what's over here?
Like, we do this out of love for you.
Okay, that's the bench.
Wait, what?
What's over here?
Oh, there's a bench here.
I like that.
Wait, there's something here too.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, they're all so fast Oh my god, they're fucking me up guys Oh my god, they're actually fucking me up right now What?
I was so close to the bench too They just went burr They just kept drilling I just casually ran up to them Look, I have zero patience right now I
You can tell that I have no patience for their bullshit and then I died because of my stubborn ass That's fine at least this parkour is not like too bad Famous last words oh My god, oh
As I was saying at least this parkour ain't too bad Are you
serious that's so fucked up that's so fucked up why was he there oh does he like reach oh where does it i was like wait the it reach in
oh my god that's that's fine we're fine we're so fine everything is okay i have no patience no they have kidnapped me
but it is over here Okay, we gotta go back up.
Get trapped.
They have kidnapped me.
I don't know where it's taking me.
I'm in baby jail right now.
Okay, let's grab this chair.
Streamlight.
Okay, that doesn't...
That has to be the chair.
Oh my god.
Oh, nice.
Another key.
What do I do with all these keys?
have too many now what is down here anyway oh there's like something in that meta yeah but like i have too many i think i used it for majority of this place is here i'm pretty sure what's over here i never been down here before whoa oh my god it's the shortcut to blast the steps
Wait, there is something down there.
What is that?
You see that?
Is that secret or is that bait?
Guys, is that secret or is that bait?
Yeah, I freed the green bug.
Both.
Okay, guys, it can't be both, guys.
Alright, what's in here?
Oh yeah, no, it is both.
You're right.
Never mind.
You were right.
It was indeed both.
You're right.
It's secret bait.
I don't know why I doubted you.
You're indeed correct as to what that was.
Alright, now we go the hard thing.
The actual parkour shit.
But how the fuck do I go up?
Oh.
That works too.
Oh my god, that doesn't work.
Oh, down.
Okay.
JK.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Oh my, because of course.
No, of course.
No.
No, no, that sounds right.
That sounds right.
Down is up.
You're right.
Are you serious?
Are you?
How?
How do I do this?
Fast enough.
Too slow.
Oh my gosh, I have to focus so hard.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I almost stumbled there because I didn't know what it looked like up top.
I didn't I didn't know
Jesus no no no Oh my god No
I still managed to fuck it up despite everything I hate this area.
I hate this area so much.
Holy shit.
That's actual hell.
Oh my god.
And like, I don't I don't know if there is a bench.
I don't have to do this parkour all over.
Let's see if I can...
There you go.
God I want to kill this guy too.
Thank God.
That's okay right now.
Oh, fuck it.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let's try this again.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
All right.
I focused.
I focused for real.
Oh my god.
Did I have a lot of money on me?
Yes.
Oh, I don't even, okay.
Guys, did I have money on me?
me guys if i have money on me i don't fuck it i don't care i don't know oh my god it was a hundred dollars i did it for a hundred dollars i
i it up it's over wait what wait wait oh my god it fucked out it fucked out let's go i
fucked up no
this i like forgot what it looked like so oh
my god thank god okay okay there we go
okay i'm dead i'm oh
my god please this is over it's over i hate it if the this parkour so badly.
Oh my god, it's over again.
I already fucked it up.
I didn't know it was over.
Oh my god, I knew it was over.
This is my purgatory.
This is my purgatory right there.
Oh my god, the thing is, I don't know if I can bug it again.
I wish I could I don't know how I did it.
I know I felt how close I was.
Oh my god, I already messed it up.
All right, I'm full focusing.
I was full focused, I swear.
Okay.
We got here.
All right, full focus.
This requires all my concentration right now.
I made it
Oh my god I made it Let's go I was not lying When I said it requires My full concentration Oh my god thank god we got the shortcut Take a fucking god We did it Okay let's go down and then grab Oh my goodness Okay let's go down and grab the bench Real quick Okay Okay.
Yeah.
I'm not doing the run back from all the way there.
Oh my god.
I should stop going so fast.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
God.
This boss better be fucking worth fighting for.
I swear to God.
This boss better be worth fighting for, chat.
I sacrificed everything to be here.
Smile.
Yes.
Yeah, I had a feeling you weren't gonna hit the fucking chat.
Shit, bitch.
There you go.
Now we're here.
Oh, God.
How could there be more?
Okay, it's a simple parkour.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
It's not...
We're not timed.
That's okay.
I take not being timed.
I take those.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh my god, there's a gauntlet.
Oh my god, it's him.
Oh my god, I remember you.
I killed your wife or your husband or either.
I don't fucking know.
And I'll do it again!
That's right!
Oh my god, you have kids!
Oh shit.
Ow.
He just keeps going.
Oh my god.
He's so fast Holy shit.
He's so fast now She was pregnant.
Oh my god.
It was the wife Friend
Okay, there we go Jesus I hate that move so much Okay, and I know he comes back again Here we go.
Jesus Christ.
How much HP do you have?
Whoa.
Oh my god.
I'm doing like pattern recognition right now.
Friend.
There we go.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Now your kids will be orphans.
right i wanted you to live a long miserable life knowing that i killed the love of your life but now now it's even better now i made your kids into orphans let's go you monster took you the orphan making
that's right wait there's a bench Where the fuck is that bench?
Liars.
Now they become Batman.
There's a- I thought that was it.
I thought that was all- There's another one?
Apparently another is based- Oh, this is all- This is the one where he talks about the main thing.
There.
Oops.
Alright, that was done accident.
I just casually.
Is there a bench right here?
No, it's just bait.
It's always bait.
It's never real.
Life ain't real.
This world.
It's always here that bait me.
Okay.
Whoops.
That might have been Lord.
Let me reset it.
There we go.
It's like I never broke it.
At water source and corals.
That's the rule.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
The porch cut it.
Conch cut it.
Oh, there's the chair.
Oh, I guess he was used to be king of this place.
What the fuck is this?
Oh.
Oh, it's the thingy.
that he's real.
Yeah, now I can do simple geometry.
Okay, I assume this guy is for later.
Wait, you just died?
Wait, the men just died there with him?
What the fuck?
All lost to fear.
Remember our rule.
Now none to resist but us.
Remember our strength.
All to bow.
rule alone against the pill how do they die like why don't you just fucking get food how did you guys die just because he died you all decided to die they died oh they got silk even these guys where's the silk at oh i see the silk on him yeah they got aura farming i see silk on the king but I just got tired of parkour.
Me too.
I...
Oh, was it him that was gonna get really hard?
Was it the...
Was it this guy that was gonna get really difficult?
If I...
Um...
If I didn't kill him.
Before Act 3.
Oh, that's why I see you.
Okay.
I mean, he was like not that difficult.
and it was just pattern recognition.
Like, he was very predictable.
And I don't have, like, the stupid swamps.
Like, even though he...
Sorry, even though she brought, like, her kids to the fight, which is pretty fucked up, not gonna lie.
Bring your children to settle your disputes.
Like, that's fucked up.
That's...
Wait, top, right?
What?
What's the secret room?
Guys, but...
Is it required?
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, what do I get out of it?
What do I...
What do I get out of it?
I'm...
I...
I am...
Do I negotiate with terrorists?
That's the thing.
What...
Just bring your kids a boss fight, Dave.
More...
Brady!
Okay.
A blue tour that increases silk damage.
Do I need that?
Guys, I don't have enough room.
I...
Cool things to do cool.
Okay, I'll look at the boss.
I'll look at him.
It's always negotiable.
Do I negotiate with Terris?
That's like...
That's the one thing I need to know.
Do I let you negotiate?
Okay.
All right, we'll see how we'll see we'll see.
All right.
I assume it's here.
Where is it?
Up?
How do I get up?
Top, right?
I can't do it.
What?
Dog line, then double jump.
Oh, there we go.
Jesus, what the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
The vault nest.
Oh my god, it's explosion, isn't it?
Oh my, oh.
I don't like this place.
Why would you take me here?
See, this is why you don't negotiate with terrorists.
This is exactly why.
It's okay.
up why did i negotiate with you guys
which way do i go right or left chat right or left
could not mean it but fun okay
okay oh you waited until i went in the room to tell me that didn't you Of course, of course, of course, of course you wait until I come in here to tell me it's not needed.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Okay, it's literally just patterns.
Alright.
Okay, that's fine.
Are you serious?
right there.
Okay, friend.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Because I have to keep looking up.
So sometimes I don't see it.
Alright.
Jesus.
You can get cornered from here so easily.
There we go.
That's...
Okay, don't tell me you have a part two.
Don't tell me.
There we go.
I was gonna say, you do not deserve a part two.
You just...
You absolutely does not deserve a Sage 2 fight.
There we go.
Yeah, that was easy.
Thank God.
He does this.
No, he doesn't.
He does not deserve anything.
Wait, what's it?
Right side?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, inspect.
I ordered an outcrop.
What?
That's it?
Is this just lore?
Oh yeah, I have a lot of super crits for some reason.
Oh, I can leave now.
Oh yeah, it's my nerd's book.
Of course it does.
Everything is nerd related.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh wait, that's nothing.
Whoops.
Okay.
How do we go up?
Oh, there we go.
Now I'm a shortcut.
There you go.
Oh.
I what oh my god okay I don't know how okay that was scary oh my god that was so scary oh my god anything that could go wrong literally just went wrong today no
where am I I don't even know where I am oh my god I'm back here Oh, thank god.
I forgot where I am.
Down is so hard.
Guys, down is scary.
I keep walking.
I can't hope it I'm a bug.
It was glowing.
It called for me.
I can't help it.
The sapper calls for me.
me.
I saw all my brethren died the same way.
But I was like, I'm different.
I told myself I'm the one that will tank it up.
Okay, where is my thing?
Oh, where is it?
Here it is.
Oh my god, it's literally right there.
That's the part that sucked.
I'm pretty late.
Okay.
We can go straight down now.
Alright, now we get the rest of the fleas.
God damn it.
God, fucking...
Okay, let me get out of here.
Oh my god, I just hit everything.
That's fine.
I'll make it.
This has been the filler of all filler episodes.
Okay.
Chair.
Alright, now we get the other fleas.
Okay, where am I missing them?
I feel like I'm missing a lot because I know like, um, I didn't do, I didn't buy all the maps.
Okay, here.
How do I get here?
I'll do the exhaust organ and then, oh my god, that's bio water.
Maybe I don't do exhaust organ.
Maybe.
No, I can.
I'll do exhaust organ way, and then I go here back to sin, I guess.
And then there's one more that I was missing somewhere else.
I saw it, too.
Am I missing another flea?
Yeah, here we go.
How do we get this one?
Where's the secret passage for this?
Where was the secret passage for this one?
Below it?
Right here?
Is it this?
I'll do Mount Faye first.
Okay, what's the climb up?
Okay, this way.
Okay, I just need to know the climb up.
Alright, let's go.
At least I can't freeze.
Because I have, I don't know.
Do I have pants on now?
Ada!
Wait, where is it?
Closest is... the slab.
The slab is the gnosis.
Yeah, apparently I put on some pants.
Oh, it's this way.
Too hot to freeze.
Exactly.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Is there an easier way?
Just fucked.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh, this way.
Wait, actually?
Grab, we'll go this way.
Yeah, this way is easier.
Parkour it is, I guess.
It's fine, I can't freeze anyway.
Whoops.
I can still mess up, apparently.
Wait, what?
How do I get up here?
Oh, wrong way?
Oh, from the outside.
Oh, here?
Oh, yeah!
Guys, it's been so long since I did this parkour, like, I legitimately don't remember.
Okay, yeah, I can do this way.
Okay.
There you go.
easier because I literally have all the good shit right now okay it's still a lot easier I just I got a little overconfident there there we go okay there we go
God, this is stupid parkour.
Alright, nice.
And then it should be up top...
Yeah.
I forgot he existed.
I forgot.
A little booby trap right there.
Alright.
Me and myself.
Thank God we needed that, actually.
Okay.
So it's somewhere here.
Not the team who cameras.
I know, right?
Oh, I knew it.
It's a fucking secret.
Oh, my God.
We gotta break some ice, too.
Oh, I can die.
Oh, there he is.
Goodbye, child.
I freed you.
Don't worry.
I'm here to save you.
Alright, now we can go.
can go sin my god i forgot that is just for poe going all right now we can go home how the he got stuck i don't question it they're very stupid they're very very stupid children where am i oh i'm going there right yeah it's this way okay rude.
It's not rude.
Some kids were just stupid.
Like, we're just stupid, and you can't fix it.
You just gotta accept it.
It's just life at that point.
Not every child is special.
Some of them are extra special.
Alright.
Raymore.
It's accurate.
Okay, we gotta go to Sinner's Road.
Yet again.
God I should have got I should have got him when I was at Sinner's Road
Okay I'm gonna rest up real quick Gotta Get Kill my wounds Time up My favorite place You know Now that I went through Bowater Sinner's Road is not that bad Count your blessings Truly a count your blessings moment It could 100% get worse.
Now she gets it.
I feel like I've been went through this so long.
Hit up.
Right.
I gotta remember how to get there.
I also gotta grab the...
Grab the bench too, just in case.
I don't trust myself.
all right he's already free there's no man inside there i don't know what you're talking about
okay this way let me up
jesus christ he was he was just on top i can't help it this big badass just got me
all right free him again
look if he wants to stay jailed for his crimes i can't stop him so how is it here oh my god he was just sleeping oh my god oh my god there was a dog here there was a another bad dog here i can't believe it he was just sleeping oh that that had to be the easiest one Out of all of them,
that was actually the easiest one I've ever got.
That's crazy.
Why is it over there?
I've never been over here.
Is it even worth it?
They're all sleeping.
Is this lore?
Oh, it's all silk eating!
Oh!
Wait, is this skill?
Wait, wait, no, this is not lore.
Oh, wait, it is!
It's a chair!
What happened?
Hello?
I saw you.
I saw what you did.
Strong you are, mistress.
Small.
But so deadly and your sin will age.
See, I come to claim you and I am...
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm not come to claim you.
You are your own free man.
I'm yours.
I am your humble slave.
I have no interest in mastery over you.
Sir, if my slain of these creatures aided you, it was merely by chance.
Farewell.
Farewell?
No!
The strong claim, the weak.
Oh my god, he's fucking freaky.
And the weak must serve.
I am yours, my mistress, and you must step.
Oh, I have to protect you too.
I feel prepared for the coming, my mistress, my powerful mistress.
While you're away hunting, I'll grow you something good.
takes time return to me soon and you may have what i grow so what does he grow oh you freaky ass man so what does he grow does he does he grow the silk eaters okay i had a feeling he had like a whole collection there oh my god oh my god it's i'll just looking at chat.
It was everything that could have happened happened to me in that room.
That's fine.
We'll just
go down.
Are you serious?
It rolled.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god.
It did everything I didn't want him to do.
That's fucking I hate this.
Truly the worst.
One last tip for the road.
Then I'll never come back here until I have.
Until I come back.
Or act 3.
Until it gets so much worse than act 3.
Alright, just in case.
Because I don't want to.
If I die I don't want to go back.
I don't want to do the fucking ultimate run back.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting the dogs.
It's fine.
Oh, wait, there's something here.
Let me see.
Trap myself in the corner is always a good idea.
Okay, it was just $5.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Truly the investment of the lifetime.
Whole $5, guys.
you don't understand that five dollars that's gonna that's gonna go so good in the long run five dollars is five dollars you're so right all right now i want to make sure we have all the fleas so wait actually i don't know what i have to do which one would be easier to go first do we get the cogs first fuck it let's get the let's get the crest and cogs first before we Let's go see the fleas.
Grand Bell way.
Yeah, let's get the cog thighs and the crest.
I have a lot of money, don't worry.
Oh, wait.
This is not what I want to do.
Where is it?
It's down here.
Okay.
Where was the cog thighs again?
Is the high...
Is it here?
Oh, it's here.
Yeah.
We'll have the cobflies first.
I have the craft metal.
Yeah.
How many craft metals do I have, actually?
That's a good question.
I have two.
Just enough.
There's a key room here.
I don't even remember.
I think it was, like, right here, right?
Dude.
oh what the fuck oh i'm glad i wiggled my way over here what a bounty's been laid out by our benefactors those generous conductors giants amongst bugs they are all seeing and dying it's beautiful here goodies are everywhere only enough for one though dear so don't be greedy you know i got here i killed all these people first what the fuck oh man i keep skulking around here while working buy something.
Oh, I could buy something from her.
Oh, I can buy craft metal.
Yeah, fuck it.
Might as well.
So much money.
Wait, how much was it?
I'll get 120.
Sure, man.
Alright, loot is loot.
Biner's keeper.
How was I supposed to know you had stuff?
Oh, there's a key area.
Okay.
Sure.
Where's the cogs tool, though?
That the cogs eyes.
Hello?
What's this?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, up in one of the left rooms?
What is...
What is this?
Oh, is it the string?
Oh, it's the string thing.
Okay, fuck that shit.
I don't have enough money for that.
I don't have the privilege for that.
Oh my god, I forgot what these guys.
God, I can't trust anybody.
places here.
I knew it.
Oh my god, that was bait.
Then I looked, this is what you could get.
Hee-hee.
Look at all the money you can't have.
Whoa.
Is that cool?
You could have had all this money.
Just lying there.
Oh my god.
What the fuck do I?
I forgot how Up across this.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Jesus.
Noink.
My money now.
I deserve this.
Finders, keepers.
You know what they said.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
More money.
Yay!
I'm rich.
So much money.
Soon as this is a secret.
This is a shortcut.
Oh my god, I almost unlocked that.
Oh, it is shortcut.
Nice.
Oh my god.
It's worth it.
Guys, it was worth it.
You guys, you don't understand.
For more money.
more money less problems you know what they say okay rosary cannon the fuck is oh my god it's shoot out my money isn't it it's that's like that's a rich person's problem they have just so much money they just money gun yeah that's the fucking money gun guys i i don't i'm not that rich guys I don't have that.
I don't have that kind of money in this game.
Just farm it for it.
It's up here.
No, that's a baby.
Uh, oh my god, it's so far.
Wait, can I even?
I should be able to, right?
I think so.
I think I can choose this.
No!
Wait, I could cheese it.
I could cheese it.
Oh, I was doing so well.
He can, but not necessarily sane.
Okay, it's not fun.
Okay, I believe you guys.
I don't think I was having fun.
I think you're right.
It did not seem that fun.
But I was doing it.
Okay, I have to go from here.
Okay, from here.
Okay.
There's a breakable wall?
Where?
Where was the breakable wall?
Wait, what?
On the pipe?
Like, back there?
There?
Oh, I see it.
Okay, there we go.
I saw it.
Hey, what's over here?
Oh my god, there's more stuff.
How do I get up there?
though.
How the fuck?
Oh my god, I hear those goddamn bats.
The bug bats.
It's fine.
Oh my god, it's not fine anymore.
I lied when I say it's fine.
Guys, it was apparently not fine.
Okay, there we go.
So I'm still in there.
There's more.
Oh my god, it's the goddamn more.
I just
want to know if there's anything.
It's just water.
I'm just hitting water.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Now where am I?
Oh!
Wait!
Nice!
This is the easy way.
Down left for a shortcut?
No, I'm right here now.
Yeah.
This works too.
That's easy.
I needed that.
Here I go.
I'm on a little ferris wheel.
Yeah.
Okay, where do I need to go now?
Oh, wait.
There's a...
Wait, there's something downstairs.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I didn't even notice that.
Is there shards?
That's it?
Oh, that was it.
it okay it was just shards all right up i go
okay oh there's a map shards oh my god actually pressed
okay that's fine i can't get me i can get your money
good there's a mask up here apparently because i never went up top
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine.
No!
Okay, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
It's so fine.
Oh, it wasn't even a master.
It was a school.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
I just used them as platforms.
Okay, maybe I can...
Nice.
Okay, I need them for HP too.
Yay!
Okay.
Oh god, these guys.
Oh my god, I forgot that.
Oh my god, I forgot about this too.
I'm drowned.
I can't swim against the current!
I forgot a lot of things about these guys.
Jesus, fuck off!
Actually, fuck off!
I'm fine.
Oh my god, it's the left room there.
I see the room.
Okay, they go up.
Oh shit, I have to go down.
okay there you go there's the cog flies now i can make my cog fly 2hp and i dream
now i have my children just go straight down here Oh, it's just a body.
Whose body is this?
Oh, secret.
Oh my god.
We're not coming back here.
I'm not coming back.
Goodbye.
I have a guy that makes me silk eaters.
I don't need them anymore.
I don't need it anymore.
There you go.
I literally have a guy.
I have a guy, guys.
That can make me silk eaters.
Oh yeah, I should grab the cogs of my children.
There you go.
Hello.
Hello kids.
Is there three?
Max?
I don't remember.
Me and my dragoons.
Rolling it up.
Uh.
Uh, four?
Alright.
Oops.
Wait, where are it?
And since this is the underworks area, it's all the way down.
It's okay.
Me and my dragoons rolling up, committing crime.
Where did they go?
Oh, I freaked.
They don't even know how to... Okay.
I didn't realize don't know how to use elevators.
How was I supposed to know that?
How was I supposed to know you don't know how to use an elevator?
I didn't know you were fucking stupid.
How do I get across?
Wait, what?
How do I get over there?
Wait.
How do we get over there?
And she abandoned us.
Probably get over there.
The right side here?
Oh my god, it's...
Oh hey.
Is that important?
Oh, fuck it.
Clearly not that important, because I don't care enough.
It's not that important.
to me.
God, that cost me $40, too.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I was like, where did she go?
You're scattered about the city.
Each seemingly laid with purpose.
Someone wished the thing dismantled, but showed respect enough to see it stir safe.
That height is in aspired form.
Seized by the first of my line for a night of cog and blade.
In it, I my predecessors talent immense now lost forget forgotten i could never create a copy of work so so fine a night that once bore the heart tell me of them a glimmering order hogwarts sentinels so impressive majestic in function they were charged but but bound to the highest holy duty now before the creation of the core the sentinels ventured even beyond these walls to see all bugs brought forth safe to serve the citadel it's the Alright,
we're restored.
We're in the sentinel shell.
Would it give thanks for the awakening?
Or would it grieve those lands now in the lost?
In time, Maker, I may find out.
Alright, let's see.
What did we need in?
Architect's key?
Is that it?
Alright.
Here you go, take it.
Alright, that's it.
Alright.
over here.
Bro, this was...
How does this go?
Did I do this yet?
Oh, I did.
Oh, hey.
No, I didn't.
What's in here?
Oh, it's the crest, right?
Chapel of the Art.
Oh, hey, that guy.
I've killed one before.
That's right.
Absorb.
Get inside.
Add me.
Oh!
Yay!
Spin the needle as a screw.
Shredding froze.
Spend skill to rapidly craft new tools.
What's it do?
Up and D?
What does that do?
Oh.
Guess he's dead.
Oh, I can craft tools.
Well, it has nothing.
Okay.
That's cool.
Oh, wait.
I can unlock it now.
Yellow, blue.
We'll grab one yellow, one blue.
And then do we need another yellow or blue?
I feel like we can grab another blue.
All right.
Two things.
Use Architects Crest to use Light Ballad Neal nine times.
Also, buy Scuttle.
Should I save it for something?
What's over here?
Why does it want me to go here?
Is there anything here?
Alright.
Oh, I can reach... Okay.
Your learning is a unique technique spawn of Cogward Hearts.
on my part.
Bugred.
You are the first organic shell to fuse our memories.
Such behavior.
My line would believe it is impossible.
So your broad arsenal did suggest strong affinity with the mechanical craft and that's allowed access to your thought store.
Versus an impressive skill, master.
I'm grateful for the insight.
Okay.
No, I'm not spending my money.
I know what it is.
I've seen it.
I saw it on Twitter.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh, I need to like put It's okay, guys.
I know what it is
Okay, um
Um, I guess I'll Grab fast here, and then I feel like this would be strong, right?
Do that, and Oh, wait.
I'll do this first.
Oh, wait.
And then Pump this, because I need know where i am at all times oh my god that's so many tools wait that's way too many tools like i that's so many tools oh what oh i don't have silk moves anymore oh okay i just noticed that
oh i see i don't have any moves related to silk
100 uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so that
Okay.
Wait, how do I?
Yeah.
Oh, I need non-silk.
Oh.
Are you still here?
I can still heal.
I hope I just, I can't use any third powers.
Oh.
Oh, this is like with my tools and stuff.
Oh, I see.
I see now.
Okay, I still use the bench.
This charge attack is really strong, too.
What's the charge attack?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Holy shit, I'm drilling.
That's crazy.
Alright.
It's wacky?
What's the pogo?
What the fuck?
What the...
Oh, it's a charge up.
Oh, I don't...
Wait, do I...
Oh my god, I forgot I had this.
I actually forgot this existed.
What is life, though?
Okay.
What else am I missing?
Alright.
Do we have...
Do we think we have all the fleas?
I'm gonna check if we have all the fleas.
Just in case.
I'll pierce the heaven.
I don't know I actually don't know
Because I don't remember if I The thing is I don't remember if I bought all the maps for it So like Because I remember I was like I'll just buy this and that's it So I want to be sure that I bought all Okay which is the closest Petrified Ducks.
Okay, we got a petrified ducks.
Oh, I didn't buy all the maps.
Yeah.
So I am missing some.
I knew it.
I fucking knew I'm always missing things.
Okay, it's a tram.
So I need to go to the bell.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
I fucking knew I was missing something.
Because I don't think I got the achievement that got all the fleas.
Goodbye.
I left my kids in the other area.
Okay.
It's left.
Down.
Left.
All the way down.
Alright.
Time to get Oh my god.
Of course.
I forgot they existed.
Alright.
Here?
Just faster.
I guess we'll go here this should not be that bad.
Then we can go down from here.
Oh my god, wait, I just don't like...
Oh my god, I don't like the Pogo.
Guys, I might not like the Pogo.
Oh my god!
It's almost perfect, except for the fact that the Pogo...
I told you, it's pretty ass.
Wait, how many lost fleas?
It seems even the last few stragglers are now with us.
That is well, Flea Master.
My travels through this land have been far and deep.
Yet almost every reach, I met the friendly, inquisitive presence of your kind.
Your fleas have an uncommon desire for adventure, which I find admirable.
Even a seldom match by capability.
Though I am not accustomed to traveling alone, following your journey and sharing some pride of this progress has been a warm thing.
too.
Have you...
I'm so happy too.
Have you made me fleas?
I would be honored to bestow one final gift onto you.
Miss Chalernet, a treasure from three kinds glorious past.
May I mark you forever as a friend to us all.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I got... Oh, I got everything!
Decrease the cost of silk silk skills when health is full.
Yay!
I got it all.
Oh, wait, I need to...
Alright, get him in here.
I need to replenish my silk real fast.
This does silk, right?
Yay!
Nice.
All right, let's try this out.
And then...
Oh.
Then...
Oh, shit!
I did it.
Oh, that's cool.
This man actually...
Oh, I did buy all of them.
Okay, I got it all.
All right, give me...
I need to replenish.
Okay.
All right.
Me and my dragon taking a bath.
Oh wait, that sounds...
Sorry.
That sounded bad.
What?
You know what?
I'm gonna get rid of this... I'm gonna get rid of this crest.
I don't like it.
I'm not a fan of this crest at all.
Alright, goodbye.
serve your purpose.
You saw too much.
Now he's dead.
He saw too much, guys.
You did this.
Now he's dead.
That lucky dragon.
He's dead.
How is he lucky?
Time doing what he loves.
That is.
Oh, worth it.
there's one more crest is it worth it though don't i just don't not isn't didn't i get all the upgrades need oh my god am i supposed to be here oh my god again
not really all right that's good enough for me if it's not that good there you go i heard not really and i'll like i take those all right let's see it uh oops that's not what i want to do okay we got all right we got we got the uh okay but imagine rubber dragon dragon oh that's cute that's a cute idea Kidding you to see for chat.
Thank you.
I can speak when... Okay, Eva time.
We should have enough for another Crest bonus thing or whatever.
Okay, uh, we gotta go to them.
Jesus, this is actually the biggest filler episode.
I can't believe we all... This is like the infinite beach episode.
How may beach episode does Silk Song provide?
Oh my god, I...
It's not all the way down here.
Is this...
way yeah oh shit this is a look jesus credit comboed me all right time listen to my song
okay nice you
down lady
my senses resound you have grown further beyond the bounds of a bug permit me to gaze again upon your nature time I may offer clarity.
Yay!
Got yellow.
Oh, I got blue.
Yay!
Equip additional.
Yay, I got a blue.
Like, oh, cool.
That's what I already have.
Okay, upgrade.
Alright.
Beam me up.
There you go.
Wait, talk again.
Oh, I can talk again?
Alright, bring me back down.
I guess, bring me back down.
Sorry, it was never over.
Lady, if you and your travelers were able...
What?
No, I don't.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What the fuck are you talking about, guys?
Back up.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
Yes.
Alright, is that everything?
Did I finish my filler?
Go down a third time just for fun.
Breakable wall?
Alejandro, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Where is this?
Okay, what does the breakable wall bring me before I go down?
I shall negotiate one more time.
What does it grant me?
There's a mask?
Okay, I swear to God, then if you, there's no mask, you're gonna get banned.
I swear to God, are you ready?
Are you willing to bet your life on it, Dex?
Are you willing?
I bet your entire life.
This is...
This is your life.
Oh.
She already got the one.
Godspeed dragon.
Okay.
Say yes, bro.
Yeah, why not?
Alright, where is the breakable wall?
Where is it?
Alright, he's betting his entire life.
Alright, where is it?
That's a bold strategy.
It was, you know, open face off.
I already got it.
All right.
He was right that there was one, but I already got it.
So that's just a, that's a timeout.
You can, you are in a timeout corner.
You're, give him a 30 minute timeout so he can think about his actions.
Really?
all right it's not a band but you gotta think about your mistakes okay apparently I have to go here wormway is it this area is it here
is it here is it here where is it extra best silk tool silk skill silk skill it will be nightmare in act 3 of you waiting in the super chat thank you thank you is it up in that area when I where I didn't Where I didn't do anything?
Alright.
How do I get there again?
You don't remember.
Boop, boop, boop.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, I'll go.
I still don't remember.
I looked at it and then I still got confused.
There's a tool there.
How the fuck do I get the tool?
Oh, no.
Wee.
Oh, hey, money.
Yeah, I'll take those.
I don't have a magnet, so the rest will just fall down to the pilgrims because they need it more than me.
Oh, I have a Weaver effigy.
The fuck is that?
Wee!
Just float over here.
I'm too lazy.
Oh, where am I?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Wait, what's here?
Some parkour shit here.
Okay, I've seen this area before.
Oh, it's this area.
I still haven't seen this.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can hit by everything.
That's fine.
All right, we're in way.
What?
Can I just kill these?
I don't think I can.
Oh wait, I can't.
Thanks
Oh my god, it's fine when
Yeah, oh my god, it's also fine I can farm these guys
I'll just farm these guys for silk fuck it
Come on, God it takes so long It takes so long to farm them for silk.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I don't have the wanderer equipment right now.
Oh my god, it's fine.
I think it's here?
Yeah.
Alright, Apako.
Oh.
We're going up.
All right.
I've been here.
I have not been here.
What am I seeing?
Of course I haven't been here.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
That's right.
No surprise attack.
What are you going to do?
Oh my god, he's just going to jump.
I was like, what are you going to do?
Anyway.
Okay.
You can't get here.
I have spikes and then he jumped.
And I was like, oh, that's what you're gonna do.
That wasn't too bad.
That's it?
Daughter of a distant land.
We who remain have waited long.
Find our strength to yours and reclaim the future of our haunted kingdom.
All right.
Bye, Pam.
Yay!
What did I get?
Sharp dart.
Peers through enemies in a blur of blades.
Oh.
Do I get...
I frames?
Oh, it's a sharp shadow.
Yeah.
Do I get eye frames for this?
Yeah?
Oh, I do.
Nice.
Whoops.
Okay, that's cool.
Cool.
Yay!
Eye frame's always nice.
Jesus.
Okay, guys, chill.
Yeah, I can't eye frame the goddamn floor, apparently.
And then I gotta go here.
I assume...
Jesus, I even see these guys.
Okay.
What do I do with this?
Because you might have to go up.
Am I going the right way?
I think so.
Jesus.
They're so annoying.
Oh.
Is it him?
I don't see.
Oh, wait.
I knew Chase.
Now I hear the body.
I could.
I couldn't go.
Charity's underway, the twisting tunnel is enough for no distractions.
You have a red suncoat, my sister's by chance.
And it'll illustrate, short-servantly, rather unreliably seeming.
In a dark cave below here, I encountered a shell not dissimilar from your own.
I suspect your assistant may have met an unfortunate end.
for fun no surprise then that lump never shung with a talent for tool discovery now my wake-up must return with my assistant show really dying on me i touched it down for two bugs unless you have further interest in my precious plasmium gotta leave me in my peace okay let me sit down real fast nerd Yeah.
I'm curious about the equipment you have here, and the blue liquid contained within.
Sadi consumes you.
Ah, yes.
To this miraculous substance intrigues you too.
I wonder beyond wonders.
A miracle made miracle.
Clash Minium.
A natural accumulation with no equal.
A healer wounds and shrinking shells.
I expect you can even defy death itself.
That's fine.
Clash Minium, Colin.
her like before or else there's a sense of remarkable similarity the highly unlikely the gray and berry soil of the mainland could never produce something as similar as this and that is a just beautiful fact and by his meaning it was discovered by my master at the fire that's a volume hidden deep in a salt-stricken walkers i brought it to these caves under her direction
four in place.
I hashtag myself.
You have been bewitched by the Blast Medium Blue Film Club.
And you are sent them to assist me in my studies.
Sure.
What do I have to do?
Because he's a nerd.
Still has his voices on.
I shouldn't.
With two bugs I test, there ain't good discovery.
Now, before he went and died, did I have my previous assistant see that the war is below?
With Blast Medium Bads.
The buds should be rifling as you see, and the weaver nectar within must be extracted before they reach maturity.
With the right to one claw, collecting the nectar is easy for success.
I even lend you my own needle file for the job.
Once you locate a bud, simply charge the file until ready.
Then release its needles into a bud's core.
Do it right, and they'll suck out the nectar in one cream pop.
Return them to me when you treat the necessary things.
samples.
If the right nectar and the right testing, Flash Minim can reveal even more of his wondrous properties.
Alright.
Don't need us.
Okay.
Wait, how do I do it?
Uh...
What the fuck?
The Pierce...
You must first be charged to full attention.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta find the buds, I guess.
I don't even know where they are.
It's been so long.
Ow.
I mean, lucky me, I guess.
There are any up here?
Wait, where am I now?
Oh, I'm out of a shortcut.
I don't even remember where it is.
Guys, it's... I feel like...
I don't remember where it is.
Oh, there is one.
Oh, there's one.
There we go.
Sucky, sucky.
How much do I need to get?
Oh, two out of three?
There's one.
They're all in that cave.
What cave?
All right.
Two in lower left area.
Okay, so I have to go lower left.
So I have to go this way.
It's fine.
See, Bago, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
So a bald scientist in a secret lab needs us to help him make his blue drugs.
I see you.
I didn't break.
Alright.
It's like, where did the assistant die?
I don't remember.
Where's the other one?
Where are the other two?
I don't remember when I found an assistant.
Here?
Is it this one?
Alright.
Is that all of them?
I'm just like, I don't remember how he died.
Okay.
Put it down.
And it should be...
Oh my god, get it out of here.
There we go.
This must be where he died.
Oh my god, I vaguely remembered this place.
This place fucking sucks.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, that's right, get out of here.
There we go.
Oh wait, I see the blue plants.
Oh, there it is.
Whoops.
Sucky, sucky.
Alright.
Then you should have one more here.
Where's the neck here?
Where is it?
I'm still missing one more.
more.
Wait, where's the next one?
Guys, where's the next one?
Right.
To the right?
Here?
Is it here?
Or here?
No, he was dead, dead.
We saw him died a long time ago.
Oh, just search it.
Oh, it's still in the big room.
No, we saw this guy died a very long time ago.
I remember seeing his body.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I hate all of them so much.
I hate, and I hate the Cs, too.
This entire area is just actual hell.
Actually, stop.
Why do they keep coming?
They don't stop coming.
No, I...
Oh, it's not here.
My body is just filled with hate, and it's not here.
God damn it, where the fuck is it?
Are you serious?
And then the fucking...
Oh my god, he comboed me.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
We were not supposed to go...
Wait, isn't this where I just came from?
This is where I just...
Oh my god, they're infinite spawning.
I just realized that.
It's in the same room?
I don't see them.
Is it in the same room as I found it?
This is where I found it.
Right here, but there's nothing else here.
It's just a plant.
See?
No plant for you.
Nothing in here.
It's more right.
It's not here.
Oh my god, there's two of them now.
There's two of them.
Maybe I go this way?
That's why you can't catch me now.
And when you see here, maybe it's down here.
Maybe?
I'm farming for silk.
I need silk.
Okay.
The slow farm.
Man.
We're almost there.
There we go.
Maybe here?
Oh, my god.
There was- it was a dead end.
It was just bait.
A forking course.
It's just bait.
Oh, a fucking course.
Everything is just bait in this cruel world.
It's all bait.
Everything is just bait.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This place sucks.
I hate this place.
Okay, it's not here.
I went down here too.
Are you sure it's in this room?
Like, I went everywhere.
I went here before I remember.
Yeah, because this is where that monk was.
Yeah, follow the blue...
Are you sure there's two here?
I feel like it's here, isn't it?
Yeah.
I knew it.
I knew you guys didn't know either.
I fucking knew you guys didn't know either.
I know I went through everything in here.
I knew it.
I was like, there's no way there's two in this room.
Okay, someone said here.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking thought I knew I should have trusted myself.
I knew it.
I knew it was in that room.
I was like, I guess you're not in this room.
I was like, I fucking knew it.
You guys, yeah, fuck it.
I'd kill it.
We were like, no, there's two in that room, Doki.
Trust me.
This is why I have trust issues.
This is exactly why.
Oh my god.
Grab more stuff from these guys.
They're like, no, there's two.
I swear, there's two in that room.
Like, I should, all right.
Demon chat doesn't trust chat.
It should have known.
Oh my gosh, what?
What the fuck?
Why can't I do this jump?
There we go.
I was like wondering why I couldn't do that jump.
It worked before.
It's fine.
I don't care anymore.
Crushed no one.
Hello.
Are you sure how those will work?
Have you extracted a sufficient amount of Plasminium for him?
Yes.
There you go.
Ah, he's actually not a kind amount of satisfactory effort, Assistant.
Or is the spare Plasminium extracted as he finally comes to understand this wondrous substance?
Money!
One last round.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
You have to bring yourself a capable assistant.
Take this delightful implement of my own invention.
A plasminium fial.
Or that you can extract precious bad mania straight into your body.
Almost painlessly.
Your true discerning looks sharp enough to pierce my shell, sir.
Why would I want to do so?
Because filling your body with plasminium is so inefficient.
It protects you from harm.
And it feels so unequivocally good.
Good.
I am such a good, I've been injecting Plasminium into the local fauna and fauna since we arrived.
No effects have been observed.
So we can conclude that the process is hardly completely safe.
Keep using the Plasminium file and enjoy all the wonderful effects it has here on your body.
If you ever run out on Plasminium, be seen again, I'll charge up your groceries for refills.
You can be confident every beat goes the words I've my touch that these okay cool no side effects what kind of drug is this wow that's crazy no side effects at all zero
wow who would have thought that that could be possible use it with the one day drug with no side effects that's crazy surely he's right yeah oh poison contaminates it rw thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you hey dokey bug did you hear about the lore of this game so like a thousand years ago after the tacos were assassinated queen stick but sink bug fought bravely against the map bugs but was ultimately defeated by douglas hugh the radiance and uh thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you okay we'll grab the cop guys first All right,
well, I mean, what do I have?
Okay, want me to try using it nine times?
I'll do it
Wait, the sitting on the bench resets it?
Oh, I need architect.
Oh Okay
All right, let's see.
Let's try it out
He's like oh that looks good.
Whoops.
What?
Um, forgot a craft.
Um, oh, I don't have enough.
Oh, fuck.
Oops.
I forgot one simple instructions.
Oh, my God.
I don't want him to hit me, though.
It's fine.
We'll have this.
I think I forgot something.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it took a- Oh, my God.
Okay, it better be worth it, guys.
2, 4, 6, 8, 9.
Oh shit, what's that?
I don't know what that is.
What did I get?
Oh, I can regen now?
Let's try it.
Oh shit, yeah, it is regenning.
Is that forever?
So if I sit on a chair, does it reset?
I'm an addict now.
Yay.
Yeah?
I'm addicted
Whoa shit It resets when you bench or fast travel Okay Well goodbye Actually let's just get to the fast travel first Actually I vote Wait so it's not a Guys it's not a side effect Oh my god it's fine Do you think about it?
It's technically not a side effect.
Oh my god, we should...
Which way is faster?
Actually.
Uh...
Where am I?
Actually.
Uh...
Down and right.
Down...
Right.
The bone bottom.
Alright, we'll do that.
Bye, Pilgrims.
You regenerate, you're not important.
Yeah, it costs a lot of shards.
Oh, hey, look.
Oh, my God.
What is the range?
Wait, this range is...
Wait, I've never seen these guys before.
It's because I killed...
Oh, it's because I killed their natural predator.
It's fine.
He said no side effects, guys.
You not trust him?
You literally said no side effects.
Alright.
Now we should be ready to go.
We got everything, right?
We can go kill- kill her again.
If I ever see that, I mean, we'll go now.
Yeah, we got everything.
Will I talk to the old man first?
Okay.
Eita!
Oh, wait, you guys told me to do the Shakira fight, right?
How do I do that?
Nah, I'm not gonna do the architect.
Press.
Bellheart, right side.
All right.
At Grimoire.
Why require...
Okay, which quest should I use?
Stop.
Here's been good to me, but the wonder apparently is the most OP, so we'll use the wonder.
Uh, we'll use poison, and then we can get rid of...
don't really fucking it doesn't really matter we have all the tools we need here
all right here we go it's time
yeah it's time dragoons it's time ring ring
hornet wielding needle with my master's passing i resolved to improve my skills in time i must do to achieve that goal i found this wide bare stone fine ground on which to train will you spar with me now raise that blade and test my rings you may prove my greatest challenge yet all right i guess we die here pond the stone let us test our skills sharka or shakira oh my god oh my god good luck oh my god oh my god good luck to me apparently Dragons!
Why aren't you helping?
Dragons!
Oh my god, they're all dead!
The dragons, they're all dead.
Oh, shit.
Last, my last one.
I'm kidding.
It's like a little hard.
Holy shit, maybe I won't fight her.
Okay, I think I need to use Silk's thread for...
Oh my god, I hate her.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, they're all gone again.
Christ.
Nice.
Oh god.
Jesus Christ.
I hate these.
Oh my god.
I have to focus so hard.
No!
Oh my god, dude.
He did two hits.
Get over here!
I want a rematch.
okay how many how many uh how many does she have what the
jesus christ she's so fast
jesus okay i didn't expect that friend
Thank God.
Okay.
I'm trying to concentrate so hard right now.
There we go.
Okay.
Good roll!
Oh!
Where did she go?
Sometimes I'm like, Where did she go?
No, you fucking kidding me.
Oh my god, that's so unlucky for me Oh my god No, wait, yes friend That's right.
I win I win you canceled my move, but I win On Duke Welsh Instruct to face the fury of your weapon in a true battle with being experienced indeed I'll gladly duel you again if you have the time.
That's it.
What?
That's it?
Poor strap Yeah That's it my reward is nothing My oh my god Another time I can't believe it all I my reward was nothing
It's literally no prize Wow I can't believe it I got a journal entry Oh my god I'm so fortunate Oh my god I'm so lucky Oh Doki should be great fun Well I'm so lucky and honored Now it's the song cave time Oh my god We're finally almost there.
I don't know if I can first try it again, honestly.
I was so lucky.
The last one we first tried, the final boss.
I was honestly very lucky.
Let's see this way.
And my reward was the friends I made all along.
Not fine.
We don't need shards.
That's fine.
Oh, here?
Sir, I have items requested.
Crafts me your trap that we may set lands free.
Alright, here you go.
I granted the wish.
Found it all, did you, Perringer?
Then join me and let the get- Let's get to prepping.
I'll be asking both your silk and your claws for the construction.
Alright, we go travel.
It's time the parts are prepared.
I'm heading now.
Now I'll just set the trap.
Even the trap blade?
Best be guessing, her on top won't go down so simple.
She'll sense what's coming.
That blade of yours is gonna have to do its work, for this thing can snap.
I expect it such, sir, and I'm ready.
Set your snare.
I shall tend shortly.
Alright.
It's time.
Here we go.
One last round.
You know what?
Sing me one last song, Shermo.
oh all right that's all i get i guess um i have everything i need i feel like i don't I have, like, not a lot of yellow tools anyway, so it's fine.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
What am I doing?
I do not need some of these tools.
Oh, it doesn't matter, because I already...
Yeah, it doesn't fucking matter.
Actually.
Alright.
We have all the fleas.
Yeah, we collected all of them.
Okay, how do we get there again?
It's been so long.
Um, fuck, it's all...
Okay, oh, nice.
We have a tree.
Thank God.
I was like, oh my God, there's so much parkour.
But it's fine.
We have the terminus.
Alright.
We got to do this.
Yeah.
I don't know if I can do this first try.
Because like.
I just got really lucky.
So we'll see it.
I was very.
Oh yeah.
at the bench.
You're right.
I almost forgot.
Down I go.
It's like I never went.
It's like I never went back there.
Almost forgot at the bench.
Forgot existed.
Just like on the goddamn pipe.
Wait, do I have...
Does anyone actually geared up for it?
Yeah, I am.
Actually!
Okay.
I don't think I need poison.
I'm thinking about it.
Because I feel like I'll my silk thing more than the poison i was like wait i don't need the poison because like i feel like decrease would help decrease the cost i feel like silk skills oh wait no um put that here i feel like uh because like i don't they'll die so fast you know they'll die so fast i might as well another stuff Yeah,
I think that's better.
I just feel like they'll die too fast for me to use it.
I just have the cogs there for a bit.
Do I have Threadstorm on?
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I do.
I always use Threadstorm.
Alright, here we go.
See if...
What?
Oh my god.
God.
Wait.
I'm gonna say, how the fuck am I?
I'm gonna say, how the fuck am I supposed to get up here?
There we go.
Ah, you come a long way, bell-ringer.
Granting wishes, saving bugs, even rousing my soul and family to act.
The stairs that above are powered bound along its thread.
They decide it may seem a cruel thing, but there's fair strength to it.
Enough to dwell a god.
You and your The family have done me well.
I shall prove your faith in the meeting ahead.
I bring your best a bell ringer.
Call forth our great pal God.
Cut her weak, then drive the beast down atop the snare.
Contact made will stir the snare alive, but only your need of song will awaken the spell and fold.
When the moment arrives, you'll see it clear.
Okay, that seems pretty easy.
Honestly, doesn't seem too hard.
Alright.
We'll see if I can do this again.
Barama!
I don't remember how to fight her.
Like, at first, I literally, I first tried her.
I legitimately don't even remember how I killed her.
Okay, I'll try it.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, I know she's easy, but I legitimately don't remember how I killed her.
Whoops.
Oh, I forgot to set up.
Fuck it.
Oh shit, I didn't see that.
That's my bad.
Oh, fuck it.
Friend.
No, just fuck it.
Oh, nice, lucky.
There we go.
Oh shit!
I forgot about the rocks.
Don't get- Don't die to the rocks, Dragos!
Don't worry, I'll protect you!
Don't die to the rocks!
You'll be very stupid if you do!
Come on, guys!
Oh my god, fuck!
I lost track of where I was.
I got lost.
Oh my god, it's not okay.
Okay.
I don't know how I got lost like there's not a lot of stuff to look at to be fair lucky row let's go
okay nice there we go whoops all right nice there we go oh wait that was easy oh oh need it in oh
With the power of music
Oh my god, I told you she's alive The silk transfusion worked Thank god I'm a universal silk donor Oh my gosh, she's alive Oh, is that the void?
Wait, what the fuck?
alive
now she's dead
yay the void oh
oh the void is imbued into the silk that doesn't sound good oh that looks very bad i didn't kill everyone.
Okay, maybe me being queen was a lot better.
Why the fuck?
How is Act 3 the better ending when I could rule the entire Farlume?
Now I'm doomed Farlume!
What?
Okay, that's what I'm saying.
Me being queen was definitely the better ending.
Yay!
I destroyed the world.
Yippee!
Aren't I friends with a boy?
wouldn't I want everyone to get voided?
You know?
I thought I'm friends with a void.
I'm June Farlume again.
First time.
I'm not friends with a void, but I'm friends with Hollow Knight.
I'm friends with John Hollow Knight and his younger brother.
Hollow Knight Jr.
But he's like my little He's my half-brother.
My several half-brothers.
Yeah, I'm like her cool.
I'm like the cool older sister.
The void is just void.
He doesn't care.
All right.
Act three done.
I definitely did not achieve the speed running.
The speed run.
All right.
Let's do it.
Let's.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going?
Oh, wait.
Act 2 done.
Sorry.
Act 2.
Act 3 started.
Oh, shit.
Be gone, Void.
Be gone.
Yeah, I first tried it again.
Technically, second first try.
Huh?
Oh, yeah, it's a cradle.
Catgirls, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright, it's the abish.
The abish.
all right let's get our final nail upgrade before we progress i heard everybody is a lot stronger now because they're all because of the void because i made a little oopsie just a little oh wait wait is jolly bees still open give me a sec guys oh my god i was craving jolly bees and i forgot to check i didn't realize it was 10 guys i i really want jobs no please tell me no i i missed Jolly Bees!
I'm so sad.
They're not accepting any orders right now.
They're currently not available.
I'm so sad.
Why would you not?
They're not just remembering Jolly.
They're like currently not accepting any orders, right?
in jolly bees i really was craving some jolly bees i'm so sad i'm so sad why do you mean you're not accepting orders uh why is the world so cruel i killed i did so much i killed i killed a mom I'm a child.
I deserve Jolly Feast.
I did so much.
That should be like, that should be my reward.
I killed a mom and a child.
I should be rewarded for my actions.
True.
I'm so sad.
Why is the world so cruel to me?
I think that's the opposite i should be allowed go to check up no thanks wait the store is not accepting another i don't care accept my order i don't care i demand you to accept my order i demand it no jolly i just really i just really want jolly bees
Barloom needs to open a Jolly V.
That's so true.
You're so right.
Okay, maybe it'll accept my order in two more minutes.
How can it be too many people ordering Jolly V at this specific time?
I don't understand.
There's still an hour left before you close.
You can't do this to me.
Sorry, JK, there's 30 minutes before they close.
plenty of time just take my buddy i'm so hungry i was craving jolly bees the entire day but i was like no just wait don't get you can wait just a little longer just wait a little bit a few kids you can wait a little bit before you order
Restaurants aren't taking any order anymore.
Life is so cruel.
It's so cruel.
They're not accepting any orders right now.
I don't understand.
I've been a good person.
I killed the family for the greater good.
And then I doomed the entire village for the greater good.
And I let the void out for the greater good.
It was all for the great and good.
I did it for you.
Are you social boy in my house?
Why me cranky?
Why me home?
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I don't know what I did to deserve this.
Maybe they're open now.
Maybe if I click refresh, the jolly bee is open again.
Come on.
Do something.
How can you be busy?
Do you know who I am?
How could you do this to me?
Angry.
Angry bug.
I'm angry now.
I'm angry bird.
Where the fuck am I?
Do I just lose my compass?
Like what happened to my compass?
Wait, I'm so lost.
What happened to my compass?
They took my compass away.
Oh, there it is.
They could just do that.
They could just take my compass away.
That's fucked.
Oh, no.
My weak ass legs.
I never do leg game.
How did they unquip everything?
Did they, like, strip me?
Like, who stripped me?
Down I go.
Am I okay?
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
I was like, And like credits end, like, oh, she's dead now.
Oh my god, my weak ass nigs.
Please.
My weak ass, skinny ass nigs can't hold my body up.
Like, did the boy take my stuff?
Like, who took my stuff?
I don't understand.
What could I possibly have taken my things?
Oh, here these guys are all dead, dead.
Well, there's the boy.
Oh, wait, there's something over here.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, that sucks.
I have a lot of HP either.
Oh, are you serious?
Okay, they baited me.
Jolly Beast took my compass.
Damn.
At least I got full HP.
back.
Thank God.
That was cheap.
That was actually so cheap.
They're here?
Oh my god, I don't even know if it was here.
They took my...
They took everything.
It was here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Here you are.
Where is it?
Wait, where did my thing go?
Wait, what?
Where is it?
Where is my cocoon?
Oh my god.
Fuck it.
I don't care.
I just don't know where it is.
when oh no it's that boy they're so strong now jesus christ oh my god they're so strong
oh my god you can shield yourself too okay friend
jesus wait did they do two damage Wait, how much damage was that?
Bro, they're just regular guys!
Oh my god, that means he does poor damage, doesn't he?
Oh my god.
This guy does poor damage, doesn't he?
Jesus Christ.
That's not fair.
When I get Embed with a boy, I still do one damage.
I'm so sad.
Maybe, wait, what's...
Maybe Jolly... Wait, I'm gonna check again, guys.
I'm gonna check again.
Are they accepting orders now?
Jolly B?
Jolly B.
Maybe it would change.
You don't know that.
Maybe it'll be different if I keep refreshing.
I mean, these guys aren't avoided.
least make up jolly bee my legs hurt it's too late thank you i can't even bro i can't even jump bro just take off the mask
jesus christ poor girl only jolly bee can feel that boy the mask stays on I'm so hungry.
That's why I'm so weak right now.
And then quit.
And then I...
And that's how Act 3 wins, guys.
This is how Act 3 ends.
Oh!
Oh my god, what happened to you, Sherma?
Why do you look like that?
What happened to your cute hat?
Boy, Red maiden.
wait.
Mila Sherma?
Yeah, what has happened here?
To our safe haven?
By home?
This is what's left of it after the great breaking began.
There was that terrible noise from above.
Everything shook and fell apart.
And the black thread sprung out from beneath.
Many a poor pilgrim has already been lost to destruction.
You might have been too.
I have an offer some fleeing pilgrims who found
the black threads I may understand their source I must speak with the old caretaker do you know what has become of him as he has left you his garb oh wait he's she's wearing his shit oh yes he charged me with oh you got promotion oh and with no like increase of pay just the status nice it's like she got promoted to assistant regional manager assistant regional manager of the Assistant of the Assistant Regional Manager.
He charged me with looking after those remaining here.
Said he had to confer with his family down below.
Down below.
And they slunked away to hide in their ruined chapel.
I must pay them a visit.
Thank you, Sherma.
Stay safe and take care of your fellow pilgrims.
Oh, what's that screaming?
Times like this, we must be sure to help each other dig deep, dear one.
I'll be leaving a lot of roads to survive what's coming.
Okay, you have nothing for me.
Watch out.
They give a super chat that you think.
I'm hanging out with some dragons and we're going to get Jolly Bee.
The spaghetti is so good.
Maybe it's so open.
Maybe they're except I'm refreshing again.
Maybe it's open now.
I just want Jolly Bee's.
So like, What the fuck happened to my- Oh my god, they stripped me, the boy!
The boy, they took everything.
That's crazy.
That's fucked up.
Bro, that's like, I gotta report to HR.
What the fuck?
How does the boy took all my clothes and my freaky ass boy?
Yeah, freaking freaky ass boy.
Um, I don't think we need the poison.
Like, it's not that much.
That's messed up.
Oh my god, they took everything from me.
Alright, let's go pay the Liza visit.
Alright, let's get our nail upgrade and we'll call it here.
If we can.
Let's see if we can.
Well, the Jolly Beat is still open here.
Zero, thank you for the saving.
I'm so sad.
I was crawling.
My stomach is like gurgle, gurgle, gurgle.
And I'm like, I can't wait.
Wait, where's my elevator?
What the fuck?
He took my elevator.
He took my jolly bees and my elevator?
Oh my god, what else do you want to take from me?
What?
Are you serious?
Where the fuck am I going to...
Oh my god, they go all the way here, down here.
That's evil.
That's actually so fucking evil.
Like, he also took my elevator.
Oh my god.
It took me years to travel.
anything.
What's that?
Where is that coming from?
What the fuck?
What is that?
How do I... Oh, it's below?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's right here.
What the fuck is singing?
I'm so sad.
He has a majestic...
That's not Trovia.
I refuse to believe that was...
That's Trovia.
Trovia!
What?
What the fuck happened?
What happened to it?
The boy.
They got it.
Jesus Christ!
I'm leaving.
I'm not that desperate.
Bro got voided.
Yeah.
I was like, what the fuck happened to her?
All right.
No, I'm not going in there.
Oh, there's the void.
More HP and more damage.
See, this is...
Oh my god!
Okay, she's not voided.
That's good.
These guys are not voided.
Oh my god, they're coming.
Oh.
all right aida are you okay oh that's not aida you die oh i don't think that's a friendly dog guys that did not look friendly
new dog all right let's go let's go drag wounds you can do this fight for me did he grow up oh my god wait oh i thought you died just then oh it's here okay i didn't oh my god what the fuck is that his asshole okay that like i just i didn't know how to react to that i didn't oh my god okay that's cool okay He's just...
Okay, he's shooting shit at me.
Okay, that's okay.
He's actually shooting shit.
Alright.
Let's try this again.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
That's his asshole.
I'm like, I'm like sticking my needle into his ass.
I don't know.
I don't know how to react to that.
Honestly, I don't know.
I don't know how I'm supposed to react to it.
I guess I'll just keep hitting his ass, I guess.
Alright.
That feels like the only thing I can do.
Honestly.
Alright.
Jesus Christo.
Oh my god, that's so annoying.
That's so annoying.
Because it's that, what the fuck do I do with these explosion berries?
Like, what the fuck do I do?
No.
Oh my god, this is not fair.
It's not fair.
Like, what do I do?
What do I do?
I don't know what to do in that situation.
Just don't get hit.
It's just that easy.
Alright, all my dragons died in the war.
So, um, we're just gonna raw it, I guess.
Okay.
It's very unfortunate they all died.
Oh my god.
Shit.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Oh thank god.
Are you serious?
This is so scary.
Oh!
Sight!
Sight to me!
Fuck.
this.
Okay, I got it.
I'm gonna use my shards.
Okay, this guy sucks, though.
This guy fucking sucks.
Alright.
Here you go.
Back to the war you come.
You're coming with me to war.
Oh my god, I swear to god, if you guys don't come down here, I swear to god.
Oh, thank god.
Yeah, I was like, where are you?
I was gonna be like, I swear to god, where did you guys go?
That's it.
It's Tohotap.
Are you serious?
Are you actually serious?
He was, in fact, very serious.
Okay.
You're all still alive, at least.
Okay, I'll dodge this.
I tried.
I did try to dodge it.
I didn't dodge that Okay, I didn't dodge that I ran into him Okay, not that though I admit that was not a dodge
Okay Dragoons, I'll give you one more try Before I banish you I'll give you one more Chance to redeem yourself
You're still Stupid asshole.
What?
He did it first?
The fuck?
He did this first?
Okay.
That's fine.
I feel like I can really only hit him once there.
Are you serious?
Friend.
Oh my god, that's three.
Okay.
I did not expect that, but that's fine.
Okay, I can do two hits there.
Oh my god, fuck.
That was...
Are you serious?
I got so scared.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I'm scared for this one.
Here you go.
Oh, nice.
Wait!
Okay, I can stay here for now.
Ah!
No!
Jesus Christ!
Two hits is so scary.
Oh, no!
Fuck!
It's fine.
I only had two hits and I dreamed.
Okay.
Two hits and a dream.
Slow and steady.
Oh my gosh, that's not slow and steady anymore.
Okay.
That's fine.
Twin.
Woo!
Okay.
Oh.
That's fine.
I'm okay with taking one hit there.
Oh, second stage.
Oh, yeah, we did it!
Yay!
Arlo, we did it!
Aw, that one was like slow and steady, wins the race.
Good boy, who's a good boy?
Who's a good boy?
That's right, you are!
You are!
You're such a good boy!
That's right!
You committed murder just like mommy does every day like my real boy
look at that even he commits murder i'm petting him team cherry said that's how you pet him
oh my god you have kids you're pregnant this entire time
oh my god she was pregnant this entire time she got she was a hard-working single mom that's why she kept charging me all those fucking rosaries oh i got fast travel i can return back nice mama beast no wonder that's why she was up charging me so much on all those fucking trans system the transit system god damn it that saves so much time yeah no wonder she had like a family to support all right now i need to go here the petrified ducks and go to fleetopia single mama for all right let's grab the last nail upgrade yeah where's the pressure she's a single mom I don't see any dads.
I don't see a mill.
A-ron.
Oh, I'm always forget about this guy.
Forget he exists.
I love this, too.
Oh, my God.
Oh, fuck.
I'm so sad.
Oh, my God.
I'm just gonna run.
That hurt me now.
Combo, combo.
Alright.
What?
Where are they?
The church I sing is for the end of our old lives.
Here at the end of times, our paradise crumbled beneath us.
Lee and friend alike.
All soon to be consumed.
What a choice do we pour, rich and live.
Our cruel fate leaves us with only one task.
Dear friend, Miss Hornet, forgive us, but we beg one more.
a favor from you we accompany us in our final act where did they go wait where did they go did he kill them all
where did he go was it a call did they drink the kool-aid the pack is made then fellows steal yourself it's time it is time oh wait oh they're fine okay it's time for the The black queen pulls us all down in darkness.
Rouse yourself, please.
One last time.
Let the games begin.
What?
It's a party?
Ain't no party like a flea party.
Oh my god, that was so fast.
It's the festival of the flea.
Sacrifice the party.
Oh my god, look at this John ass meat.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Here one.
How shameful for the world to end while poor Christ still has so much living in him.
How sweet of joy will you play the flea bounce game that I may appreciate the beauty of your agile fort while away my doom?
The play is simple.
Leap up and keep bouncing on the fleas who fly past for as long as you're able to.
Okay guys, um, so how, so how do I get, okay guys?
Oh, I have to get...
Oh, Alejandro, thank you for the super chat, please.
Oh, okay.
Okay, he said it was simple.
It's free, right?
Okay.
How do I do this?
Oh.
Oh, that's funny.
I like that.
Are you serious?
No!
What are you doing?
Okay.
I got it.
Oh, thank God it's free.
Thank God.
It's not like the other flea.
The other flea was a scammer.
Okay.
I didn't...
The worst part is that it's so slow at first, too I need
full focus this though What what was he doing here?
I was not expecting him
No That was so close No, I accidentally pressed the right thing i was doing so good too
oh oh it's like random ones it's there's no pattern i just know this because okay to be fair yeah when he was like when the freaking creepy perverted flea showed up because i don't remember him being there last time jesus christ get out of here
Danny 45 oh
when they go down it's like okay double
no I was I just need six more I actually needed six more I'm so sad doing so well oh my Oh my god.
Oh!
I didn't think I.
I'm holding full focus.
I-
Okay, okay.
For real,
for real.
I need that nail upgrade.
I don't
know, I can grab that.
That's way too fast.
That's so fast now.
They're so fast.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Yes!
I got it!
They're so fast, though.
Okay, now that I got it, I can chill.
Goodbye.
I did it.
Oh, thank God.
Oh.
My dear, my dastard game has ended.
You have proven yourself the champion.
None can best your score.
You have shameless.
Oh, your fearsome grace.
You will keep playing for me, yes?
The world needs to be.
No, we're not.
Okay.
What was it?
Dodge?
Oh, does he do Dodge?
How do I do Dodge?
Nothing left but to test ourselves.
dodge stay upon the platforms avoid attacks longer stay gives bigger score the score most is to become champion this is only thing left to strive for all right dodge how many was it i don't even remember okay if i don't know that's good right okay how do i
wait where my platform go goodbye I was like, where did it go?
I can't.
Nice.
Sixty...
Oh my god, I almost...
I just need good RNG, right?
Oh my god!
That's so scary.
Can I hit them?
Does hitting count as dodgy?
Ah!
Nice save.
You can?
Oh!
Okay, I thought I had...
Okay, that's good.
I can pogo them.
That's good to know, because I...
I was like, oh god, this is harder if I can't pogo.
What?
Okay.
Oh my god, wait!
This is so hard!
Okay, I can pogo and harpoon them.
That's good to know.
I think the bouncing was more fun.
God,
when they take this away, it like fucks with me so much.
Oh.
Oh my god, big boy.
What the fuck?
What do I do when they take away all I love?
Everything I love.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
This is so rough.
You're so...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
It was too many.
I was fighting for my life.
Oh my god.
I was like, please stop.
Please, please stop.
I feel like I always have to be like, enjoy.
Okay.
Oh my god, where do I go?
What do I do?
I do when they take everything from meat?
Oh.
So much.
Ooh.
There was too many things going on.
I got PT.
I got I got overwhelmed.
Ooh.
Oh.
There you go.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This platform just, I just got on this platform.
Jesus Christ, so fast.
Um, okay, I was gonna say it.
But that's not fair.
What the fuck?
This platform just came back.
You can't just take it from me.
Doesn't work like that
How was that fair?
He took it away!
I couldn't have floated!
I had to poke him!
Oh my god, that was so bullshit.
I was literally waiting.
Oh my god.
I was literally waiting for him, waiting for my platform.
Here we go.
Literally, it's all just RNG.
It's like...
Okay.
That's a big boy.
scared about.
I just got here.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Every time the big boy, he goes so fast that I can't even pogo him in time.
I couldn't pogo him in time.
He went so fast.
I was like, do I float or pogo?
Do I float or?
I should have floated.
He went by so fast.
Yeah.
Oh God damn it
See bingo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bye
I knew it was over I knew it was over A big boy three don't you see it?
I don't know what to do when he does that
Yeah, I could pogo but also like he's so fast too Oh
Feels like he goes so fast
Oh Nice, not nice anymore.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Please, please come back.
Oh.
Put
it at the end!
No!
Oh, stupid, not fair!
You made this game!
It's not fair that you're on the high score!
It's like a conflict of interest!
She made this game!
It's not fair!
Oh, oh, oh!
I'm so sad.
sad and she attacks me too like who attacks her when she does it who attacks her calendar point oh like who attacks her when she does these games
you're locking in i can't keep doing this i can't keep out wooing i know how much you guys love it
It has to end.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Are you serious?
I literally just got here.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I'm gonna go to bed and all you can think about is
No, we're ending we're ending today with this I need my upgrade Yeah, I'm full focus I'm full focus I close my eyes and
It's literally just RNG I feel like Okay Okay, that's fine.
It's like, if you get good BDRNG.
Jesus.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Oh.
That scared me.
Oh!
It knocked me down too!
The stupid RNG.
The double tap, yeah.
RNG, bleed generator.
I feel like this would make or break the speedrun.
I mean, unless you don't want the nail upgrade.
I don't know, maybe they're too good for the nail upgrade.
Okay.
Okay, I didn't think she would hit me, but okay.
Oh
Okay Oh
Please tell me Oh god, oh my god I'm so stressed out.
I'm so stressed out.
No And everyone
like they said all the children after me oh my god it's when they send in everybody they send in so many please and they all like converge in my area okay full focus
okay now starting now that's all why did i save all of them i should have left like five 10 of them to die.
It was my mistake.
I should have left more of them to die.
Okay.
I didn't think it would curve to me.
I thought I was like, I'll just wait here.
Let's just wait here.
Okay.
getting worse now I said I had full focus and I end up getting worse
okay just stay here until it's too late I knew it I had a feeling that platform was gonna oh nice okay
Whoa!
A fucking curse.
I can't have nice things here.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
I made it.
I did it.
Oh my god.
off leave.
Impressive was your performance.
Your score exceeds even my own PC skills so nice.
Moments of where everything ends can be unexpected.
I congratulate you, champion.
I did it.
Nice.
That's worth it.
Who's in charge of the last one?
Grishkin, okay.
Nice.
Good friends of Lee is you, Miss Horton, and now must join and drink much.
Be merry before our ends.
No trash for you.
Wait, it's not him, not her.
I like our festival.
While the world comes around us, we will laugh and dance and frolic me thinking of the Super Chat thinking, thank you.
You juggled them now.
They juggled you.
Make merry of us and play some of the games of old.
My time is slim, Flea Master.
If I am to join your games, no, it will need to hone my skills for the greater trial of Masoon Faced Below.
Of course, of course.
Joy of learning.
Any reasons why my eyes must turn it.
And look here.
We have flea juggle where the challenge is strike fleas upward and keep them off.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
It's juggling time.
Here we go.
Apparently this is the hardest one.
How do I do it?
One, two, three, one, two, three, four, five.
Guys, I'm a little worried.
Oh, there's free three strikes.
Oh, I got my second chance.
I was like, why is he here?
Oh, my God.
Wait, I have to keep jug.
It's not per hit.
It's like how many I've completed juggling them.
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I get it now.
I get it.
It's perfectly.
Okay, three times each one.
Okay.
Hit them up too.
I mean, that's late.
I mean, that's the plan.
I'll jump juggle them.
Oh my god.
God, what?
Okay, I didn't realize that like, he goes so fast.
Oh my god.
He goes so fast, it's like...
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh my god!
Jumping is...
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Okay, we'll do it again.
Oh, it gets some higher, which means...
Oh, they gain more motetment.
I didn't realize they fall down faster.
Okay, now that I know, I won't do that.
I thought that...
I thought me jumping would make it so they go higher.
So, you don't have to worry about it.
I have more time, but I didn't realize They'll fucking fall down faster.
That's fucked up Jesus Christ if I didn't have enough things to worry about They gave this one they like drug that guy up
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
I got I actually I didn't realize I can't I have to stay on the platform Oh my okay.
This is frustrating Only because I have to do it three times.
Slash front is better?
Okay, I'll try that.
Oh, I didn't.
I didn't know that.
I didn't realize you could slash up front.
That makes it so much easier.
What the fuck?
All right, what?
Ooh, whoa.
Okay Oh
My god, I can't because they were all
I didn't
realize that I took him all the way there
Okay Okay
Okay, one more.
This one sucks.
Because you're so fast.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
There
you go.
There you go.
Fucking freak out.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I fucked up.
Too
many.
I couldn't juggle all of it.
Oh my god.
There was so many.
I need like what, 27?
2?
I actually split them up.
I'm just gonna do it fast.
Because like, this part is so slow.
so that there you go okay i'll hit it at like the last one there you go one three okay oh
there we go three four
No!
They split up!
That's so messed up.
Okay.
I lost two right there.
Because I got confused.
Ah!
They're all two grouped up!
They're so grouped up!
Do I need to change my crest?
Okay, we'll make it even longer.
Wait, actually, we can, actually, I realize.
because it's hunter right um let's see where's the range okay it's hunt or is a reaper no it's reaper that has the longest reaper and then we can do where's the long stop there you go that's the longest i can do oh tools don't work okay all right
Oh, it is slower, though.
You're right.
Maybe it's not a good idea.
I realize it is slower.
It might fuck me up.
Oh, yeah, I don't like that.
Oh, I'm going to swap it off.
Yeah, it's too slow.
It's way too slow.
I'm not a fan of it.
Yeah, I'm going to go back to Wonder.
I think Wonder was the best.
I don't think range matters for me.
Oh, wait.
That's the beast.
I'm not letting that piece out.
Hunter works nicely?
Okay, we'll try.
Okay, tools don't work, right?
Okay.
I'll just, I won't, I'll do it like a naked hunter.
I'm gonna try and focus as much as I can.
There you are.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Where?
Oh my god.
This is so scary.
I feel like...
I should have definitely got more from that one.
No!
I dashed!
That much!
Okay, 30!
30!
I had to...
That was a ring!
Oh!
I accidentally dashed it.
I'm so sad.
It was a good juggle too.
I'm just jumping for this.
because I want to get to these slow ones out of the way.
I'm not jumping anymore.
I'm not jumping.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
I need my final nail upgrade.
You don't understand.
Okay.
Uh, Finn, thank you for the- Oh my god!
I'm sorry!
Child, I was looking at money!
Thank you for the Ahasua.
That's my bad.
Thank you for the- I'm sorry, child.
I was looking at money.
You understand, right?
I got distracted by money.
There you go.
The ring!
That shouldn't count!
Thank you for the hacka soup, but thank you, thank you.
It was out of the ring!
That shouldn't count!
When you're out of the ring, you shouldn't be a, you shouldn't count towards my, my mistake.
mistakes
okay oh
okay one this should be like two points because like if you're making me hit like an extra point that should be two like I don't understand oh
my god oh Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god, it's five.
Oh my god, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Let them all get brain damage.
I don't care.
Let them all get concussions.
It's over.
You have proven yourself a champion of each of our flea games.
I am confident now that the grand champion of our festival has emerged.
It is none other than yourself, of course.
And thusly must our final ceremony begin.
Please prepare yourself.
You can have concussions for all I care.
I got what I needed.
Gathered here we are to honor the grand champion of this very final of all festivals.
Now, Miss Hornet, strike the great epitome of all your money.
Money!
Free money!
Oh!
Yay!
Wish granted!
My final nail upgrade.
I should have brought my magnet.
I bet all that money is gone.
Yep, it's gone.
I should have brought my magnet.
Oh my god.
Rest in peace.
All that money.
I didn't realize it was just this and here.
I thought the money would wait for me.
And so the great ceremony has reached its climax and its great champion has emerged.
Thank you for spending your last moments with us here.
Miss Horton, though the world will soon end and our paradise will crumble, the memories of friendship will all share.
Shall surely echo through the oncoming world.
Fleetmaster, your sentiment is kind, but the world will not end.
Oh, how good of you to speak words of hope for our benefit.
But we have accepted our fate.
Come, let's forget the past and rubble together it's not merely hope that i offer you sir but a promise this kingdom suffering has a singular curse cause and by my own call will it be cleansed perhaps not every flea would survive what is coming but the world will not die your settlement may see a chance to prosper ah you speak with such conviction but i cannot bring myself the hope such i am sorry come what may we fleas will be here until the end the games will continue of course celebrate with us for as long as you wish dear friend all right it's over uh it's over we might we don't have to come back here again we don't have to come back here hey guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right wait let's get our fifth let's get our upgrade before we end it today
go up one last bath one last bath in my favorite place Okay, now, now, wait, I need to change my crest.
I forgot.
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait, give me a...
Oh, you're right, guys.
I almost think I...
Taking me home, getting me out of here.
Get me out of here.
I'm never coming back.
Oh, Bellheart.
It's time.
It's time to get my nails polished.
Hello, hello, hello.
What the fuck?
Hello?
What happened?
What?
Why aren't you guys dancing?
There isn't a sea, you return.
little I was such a glimmer of life even as the dark descends upon us all all these pilgrims gathered here I had not expected so many to survive the destruction beyond these bells suggested worse indeed these things should be worse would be worse but for your tall warrior friend heard of those shining rings who so fortunate chose our town the camp that brave bugged the axe alone to guard our town and those plague pilgrims who flee for it for efforts our shells are safe the long long Shira can remain at that time I do not dare to consider.
Wait, did I do this?
No, no, it's not my fault.
Wait, how do I?
How do I punish my nail?
Guys.
Guys, how do I...
Did he got raptured?
Guys, where's the nail man?
Where is he?
Where the fuck is the grave in the ground?
I don't fucking know what that is.
Why did he speak in riddles?
Just tell me where it is.
He's in Shellwood.
Okay.
Where the fuck is Shellwood?
Why does he speak in the riddles?
Where the fuck is the grave in Shellwood?
There's a graveyard here?
Is that it?
Is that here?
Is that where he is?
Bro, why are you sad?
Alright.
Why is he sad?
I don't understand.
Your job is to appease me.
Make me happy.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I even... Oh my god.
There's so many things going on my screen.
I... I don't love I like when Shakira is here because it's so, it's really, really hard to see.
Shakira, you pit yourself against the black-threaded bugs?
Their danger is full, even for the hardened warrior.
I relish such danger.
I have little choices besides.
These creatures besiege the town within.
Their relentless, empowered.
It is a void.
Stretched up into this world in its husk, I know it well.
It's forced its nature.
But since it's soul within, it'll drive precariously towards it.
As you say, many bugs now huddled within the bells.
Nowhere else is safe with this black thread rising.
Some luck at least I chose to remain and can offer my rings as a fence.
Shakira, I seek to end this new disaster.
For it.
For in it I share much blame, but no, I shall need time to complete my task.
I need you to hold fast till then.
This town is the bugs in the garden, and I can think of none better.
Very well, Hornet wielding needle.
A pact made strong.
I shall fight with Fates Renewed.
It's so hard to see sometimes when she's fighting.
Because it's like so much clutter.
You know?
It's so much fucking clutter on my screen when she's fighting.
Alright.
It is left and then left.
And then left and up.
Okay, yeah, this way.
What the fuck?
Okay, I could be here.
And up.
There we go.
And then there's the grave.
He polished.
You might be grieving.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I thought he was having a party with his friends.
I was like, oh hey, are you having a little party?
Okay, the boy hasn't taken him.
Oh, man.
took him.
Sorry, the boy, oh, it took her too, but it's fine.
Alright, they're dead.
Oh, they're not dead.
Are you serious?
Nice, I got it before the boy got him.
Friend!
There you go.
Hello!
I thought you was having a party.
I was like, hey, why?
Well, yo, what a frightful, fearful fright, you see poor Finn from such a delight.
At long his last to see that five-needle dance and sing.
These are deadly roads to wander, Pinmaster.
Especially with the black-soldier's soared threads tearing the lands apart.
Your greatest chance for safety lies in Bellheart with your fellows.
You can protect one another and perhaps in time rebuild.
Oh, yes, of course.
Twas not Pliny's wish to ban his dear bell friends, but with the world now ending, I had to come to say one last farewell to my sweet Melitola.
I should be returning though quite rightly our town will be needing a pin master's fine work now more than ever all right
i'm not talking to you sir that is not about you it's about that fast travel all right there you go stop stop singing it's not about you
all right i saved his life he should give it to he should like polish it for free like hypothetically speaking like that should be how it works this fortune see you return pinmaster the roads between here and that deep woods grave crawl with violent foals i concern for your safety brave warrior my hero twas indeed a fearful scrambled home i feel the corner be cantanically hot for bugs thank you for super chat i even think it's bro she's so skinny she's like a skeleton how would she be provide nutrients for the children with how skinny and sticky like stick bone she is.
Stick bugs are she could barely lift her whole she could barely lift her entire body with her fucking stick legs you not remember that?
She's like oh my mask is so heavy.
In such time the task for a pin master is clear the polish and sharpener are fine especially let the glimmer of your blade and may pierce through the encroaching murk.
Alright.
how much oh my god I'm nearly missing a hundred dollars I saved your life Jesus and all you could think about is money how about 680 rosaries
world may be ending but I literally saved his life and he was like money please
oh my god you're right and he raised his prices too That's so fucked up.
I saved his life and then he raised his prices.
Carly may el, but throughout it's more you need a little shine.
Yay!
Is that full upgrade, chat?
What's my new nail?
That's a full upgrade, right?
I don't know what's different with it.
I forgot what it looked like before.
Yeah!
I don't even remember what it looked like.
It was not paying attention.
You're like, look, it's full.
Look, it's different.
I was like, it's different?
All right, we're gonna call it here, guys.
Oh, it's a pretty boy killer.
They even super chat.
Thank you.
Just finished act three yesterday and truly was worth the eight-year wait.
Can't wait to see you fight the final boss.
Oh, my God.
I feel like I know there's a lot of bosses even before I to the final boss too so we'll see i don't know if i could finish it by next playthrough guys do you think i could finish it by next playthrough or do you think it'll take me two streams chat i need to know give it to me straight give it to me straight i could depends on how long um if i do a six hour stream there's a lot okay we'll do two okay it'll be two streams all right guys i'm gonna call it here thank you everybody for watching um tomorrow it'll be a collab with mint on my channel i don't yeah on my channel um we're gonna be playing 30 rule 34 though for those who don't know what that is it's literally like which is higher like which which character or series has the most rule 34 art and we have to decide which one is it's like left or right so it's literally like which is higher basically um but yeah it's a very it was look i saw it i saw some people playing i was like oh that looks fun i was like would be a perfect
partner for it and i was like mid because she's a freak she okay i know my cartoons i know that rule 34 for cartoons and like um and live action and she knows the anime so like i know cartoons games and live action but i need her to help me with the anime stuff She's my call-up friend.
Because I don't know the anime stuff.
For Rule 34.
I'm going to call it here.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around.
And get that blood flowing.
And stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'm going to get Jolly Bees tomorrow.
It's the last thing I do.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.